thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do you guys play chess you want to talk
about it let's do oh yeah where do you
play chess at you know okay when I say
chess the first word that pops into your
mind
protect my queen Hikaru intelligence
strategy tactics Toby Maguire oh my God
you saw Pawn sacrifice if you're on
Tinder and you're scrolling and someone
has a chess player on their profile as
that swipe left or swipe right
is good right yeah then yeah instant
swipe right okay super into that right
I'm into it you're ready that's probably
whatever the swipe is I don't not
interested so you're not interested in
chess players I'm not into chess players
are on Tinder oh I get that in fact that
checks out if I ask you to name one
chess player in the world can you name a
chess player
yeah no not gonna on the tailor Joy
Capital boy name another one oh casparov
Casper you can five other world
she will give you fifty dollars
this is spasky
holgar
Carlson and
on holy [ __ ]
did you get 50 bucks dude oh my God we
just lost 50 whose idea was that
[Music]
yeah
today I'm here at the annex chess club
in Toronto this is also one of the
oldest chess clubs in the city I also
used to play in this club when I was
like a little kid
it's really cool to see that they're
doing the rapid Halloween tournament
that they host every single year
so it's really cool to see that the
chest scene in Toronto is you know
booming and everyone is here having some
fun on Halloween night
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a Canadian 10 bill right so I
want you to touch it here you see the
trophy you see this yes if you you can
walk away with it if you can tear that
bill
all right there you go yeah go ahead try
it oh this is some kind of joke yeah rip
it go ahead try to rip it go ahead try
it come on world okay what is the trick
to this champ now he broke the king so
this was he might be able to rip this
you know what I'm saying look at that
look at him look at that look at that I
can see already do that right here on
this side it smells like syrup and Duda
come on Wesley
you can rip it
that's a strong man look at the straight
you see
it can I like it
some kind of magic trick or something
yeah interesting it's uh it's
indestructible but it has not always
been like that yeah I've definitely I've
definitely ripped a couple of the dreams
she can't rip it and I'm gonna take that
back from you appreciate it thank you
thanks thanks Wesley yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah uh-huh
yeah yeah we'll be here we'll be here
okay I ain't got a watch on you know
that okay we're back after the
commercial today
foreign
[Music]
the weather outside the one Hotel
Toronto is brisk but inside the gameplay
Hall things are heating up we began with
eight competitors now only two remain
each has survived to stake their claim
to the two hundred thousand dollar first
place prize it's day one of the title
match at the chess.com Global
championship and it starts right now
yes I was born in Vancouver crazy but as
fond as I am of that place it's pretty
tough not to fall in love with the city
of Toronto
natural beauty abounds inside Toronto
and pretty close by
the largest city in Canada the people
here have been playing chess in clubs in
universities and public parks for well
over a century
and now this wonderful place plays hosts
to the very first chess.com Global
championship finals
facing elimination for weeks two of the
world's best players are one step away
from completing their quest for the
queen-size share of the one million
dollar prize pool one second now for
Hikaru he's just trying to prevent them
that was the end of his chances oh my
God what a finale
my life you're in the right place it's
time for the cgc's championship match
Toronto Canada officially has it all
just like my sister
Alexandra dude did you write this
she's asleep
wake up Alexandra we'll make sure our
friends here at the one hotel get you a
wake-up call in the game plan haul
Wesley so is in fact wide awake and
ready as well as his mom Lotus who is
here to watch her son face nihal sarin
who will be coming to us from Belgrade
Serbia
hey there everyone I'm on Hamilton Danny
wrench James Canty and Fabiano caruana
with you will soon be joined by Daniel
nerdinsky and Levy Rosman to call
today's matches later Robert Hess and
fobby will call the matches as well
fellas after months of competition the
day has come it's the start of the cgc
title match between Wesley so and nihal
sarin how pumped are we to finally be
here Danny this is the finals of the cgc
it's all come down to this that bracket
has been whittled down to just two
players out of the so many that we
started with so I can't wait to get into
the action and ultimately Crown a
champion Bobby you just won a
championship but how excited are you to
be in Toronto to watch someone else get
a championship I'm super excited the
prize fund everything at stake the
pressure on these guys youth versus
youth versus experience everything is
online and it's very exciting Canty yeah
I know you had NACA Wesley still gets
through now nihal Soren you're just I
know you're you're pumped
I never know so honey you should be
happy you're far enough away from him
that he can't do that 200
000. you ain't you ain't close enough
yeah you know yeah 200 000 man I'm hyped
man that's a lot of money it's a lot of
money a lot of money a lot of money I
don't even want to call out that second
place already gets 100 Grand because
we're focused on first place but yeah
this is this is pretty awesome so all
right let's take a look at our bracket
so and Soarin won their quarterfinals
matchups a few days ago and then so got
past Hikaru Nakamura yesterday and nihal
sarin outlasted Anish giri that puts
Wesley so and nihal in the championship
match starting today with games one
through four
as we mentioned yesterday nihal Soren
needed Armageddon to take down Geary our
own Mike Klein caught up with nihal
after his victory
[Music]
we're at the chess.com Global
championship in Belgrade with our
finalist Grand Master nihal tsar and
first of all congratulations a very
tense day thank you I understand it was
not your first Armageddon bid you bid 14
minutes and 15 seconds that tells the
world that you wanted to play White is
that right so throughout this match I
was I was a bit unsure with black all
the time that it's better to have white
and try something although I was not
really happy with the opening it just
ended well hey you had rook in two
versus rook and one did you feel like
you had good practical chances there uh
actually no so when it started I went
for this five versus four I thought then
I had good chances and I think I traded
to the stewardesses one a bit too fast
only when he played this King G6 he just
allowed me to get Rook F6 and King up
for free I realized or I thought I'm
winning and only after I played F5 I was
completely sure okay so you know you're
playing Wesley in the finals what are
your thoughts going into that match will
be an interesting match and I just as
usual I just hope to play my best best
chess and put up a good fight thank you
awesome stuff there we see again the
final score five to four nihal sarin
ultimately defeated Anish giri in
Armageddon lots of decisive blows were
traded there guys wins for both players
but in the end nihal sarn came out
Victorious you see that 1-0 spot in the
Armageddon so let's talk about nihau's
path to get here any of the matches the
comeback Victory versus Savion the
Armageddon over Anish giri I loved his
breakdown of how that game went
yesterday as well very similar to how
you and Donya were actually calling his
thought process yeah honestly that end
game was so tense Danny but you know he
I think he knew he always had winning
chances there because five against four
you can Whittle that down and I think
that just shows that's how Nihao has
continued to have success in this
tournament format right he's had some of
the closest match-ups of any of the
competitors yeah but he always seems to
get it done and that's Championship
material right there you know you've got
to have those nerves can't you've seen
all these young Indian guys come up
we've seen them win time scrambles like
that now you see them getting it done in
Armageddon with big bucks on the line
how impressed were you as a spectator
watching the big TV with me out there
yesterday well I know that man's a
professional boxer sorry has been
sparring a lot and yes you can tell I
mean the the guy took down kramnik I
mean he took down ding Loren playing for
the world championship that's huge and
then you took down you know uh Gary look
he's playing some absolutely phenomenal
chess it's in the water Bobby again
another person who's been sitting in a
chair watching Always the generation
coming up right he's so many young
talents On The Rise but when you see a
guy like nihal sarin kind of making a
name for himself sort of putting his
mark on the map how awesome is it to see
him emerge well I think he realizes how
important it is and I I can speak also
from experience because when I was
around his age I knew how important it
was those formative years and also
establishing yourself in the Chess World
and he has a lot of competition there
are so many young players
in his country and around the world that
are so so talented we have gukesh Abdul
satara of aragaisi pragnanta there's so
many players and he knows that he always
has to keep improving his game to stay a
step ahead of them or even to stay on
equal terms of them you know because
they're so also impressive and I think
this is a this is already a huge success
for him he has beaten former world
champion a current world championship
Challenger which will be played next
year early next year I mean that's like
you can't beat a more impressive racket
than he faced and beat yep all right
well you're right his path was
impressive where we're going with nihal
Soren's career is impressive but uh
let's turn to the other finalists the
American Wesley so on Saturday Nemo
caught up with Wesley after his decisive
yet compelling win over Hikaru
foreign
very happy I played Hikaru many matches
in my life I think maybe I beat him two
out of 10 times like I have a win
percentage of 20 for going to the match
I knew for sure that he was the favorite
also he's been playing very well
recently you know I figured it also
helped me that I just I came here just
wanting to play my best chess and not to
think about their thoughts at all
obviously there's a lot of money at
stake but as I said before term and
think of money will just make you play
worse but it's uh it's fun I obviously
have some questions you know about you
know some of the moves that we played
and he growth much strategy in the
opening uh and uh he was basically the
entire match putting me put into time
pressure and trying to get me to beat me
in these scrambles and it probably would
have worked most of the time but
shockingly today didn't happen
reached up there from Wesley and it was
a great match indeed we saw it was draw
after draw after draw until the
Breakthrough happened in game seven and
then ultimately that incredibly exciting
game mate we didn't need Armageddon it
was five to three final but it felt just
as intense and what a match it was for
Wesley Bobby I want to throw to you
first you've you've been Rivals with
both these guys you've been teammates
with both of these guys how impressed
were you with Wesley to do what so many
people can't do which is beat Hikaru in
those intense time scramble moments well
his path to the match against Hikaru he
had been the favorite in all his matches
we could say safely yeah but against
Hikaru it was very unclear who is the
favorite most people gave a slight Edge
tikaru and I also did I thought that
Hikaru would pull this one out but it
was very close everyone knew how close
it would be but Wesley has so much
success in these online matches he's
beaten Magnus before he's come back from
deficits against Magnus against Hikaru
he's beaten all the best players in the
world he's come just a whisper away from
winning the speed Chess Championship
he he can do it in those critical
moments so he showed that against Hikaru
yeah even though he might have been a
slight Underdog nobody's surprised that
he was able to win that match can't he
we see Hikaru beat so many people there
but Westie doesn't play as much online
when you see once they do that you go
man this boy can get it done right why
isn't he playing More in these online
events well Danny first off you hit the
gym this morning right yeah yeah of
course guess who I said in the gym big
Flex please okay he hitting him weights
very hard as you can tell this man
making it and be beat hikaro that's just
a statement in itself I mean no matter
what it doesn't matter who you beat
obviously but beating your car was a
statement always especially because he
wins everything right and he's a hot
hand out to fish a random World
Championship Wesley was able to take him
down with the engine light play very
sharp but also very dull like very dull
annoying type play where you can't crack
it and Carl got under that pressure and
then kind of fell under so come on you
picked Wesley tell everybody what you
saw then many others didn't I I picked
Wesley in that match I also actually had
Wesley like since the start of my chest
outcome bracket Danny so I just I always
feel like Wesley can be that on in these
match formats he's so good at getting it
done and I mentioned it before right
here on these chairs Danny I was talking
about efficiency I feel like when it's a
you know maybe he can squeak out a draw
but he's worse he gets the draw and
maybe when he can win but it should be a
draw he gets the win and if you do that
consistently in these like match formats
you're always going to get it done yeah
and I agree with Canty it does seem
annoying at times just how accurate he
is how technical he is the way he found
those moves and when we all thought
hikaru's Knight was going to get the job
done and somehow Wesley held on I think
he shocked the world although why are we
still shocked that Wesley continues to
impress us in those ways so let's set
the table for our match today we will
play the first four games today
games 5 through 8 will be played as
necessary tomorrow the winner gets two
hundred thousand dollars between these
two gentlemen OMGs or snaps that is a
lot of dough Wesley so versus nihal
sarin so let's talk about this matchup
between so and sarin I'm on I'm going to
start with you let's compare and
contrast their Styles talk about the X's
and O's we expect them to bring on the
board well Danny the I think the most
important thing to talk about is how
different those styles are and that's
why I think we're going to get such an
interesting matchup right we've got
nihal sarin who's kind of had you know
lots of wins but also given up you know
some games as well to his opponents so
he always feels he can play for a win I
feel like in any game right and then
you've got Wesley we've talked about
just how surgical his style is how
precise it is and I think this match is
going to be determined by who can sort
of bring the other one into their style
more at least get more of a wild match
with wins here wins there I feel like
that yeah I agree with uh what Amman is
saying it's very contrasting styles I
think that we see nihal who is known
he's sort of like a scrapper he's known
as the magician right he's Conjuring up
resources and bad positions and lost
positions and Wesley is maybe outside of
Magnus the most accurate player in the
world we see the stats or Wesley is just
tops the list in terms of accuracy even
at these in these fast time controls so
that's extreme extremely contrasting
Styles and opening wise
also totally different yeah Wesley is he
sticks to his Berlin he sticks to his
you know Queen's Gambit declined his
Italian game and Neil is all over the
place sometimes it's a pirick defense
sometimes it's this sometimes that he's
jumping all over the place that was
actually how he caused honey so many
problems he was jumping around and
finding advantage in the opening against
Hanish which is a very difficult task I
have to say and very impressive and I
think he might have some of that again
against Wesley because he can
he knows what Wesley's going to play
it's going to be Berlin if he wants to
go there maybe he can find these like
small unusual ideas don't say that too
close to Canty he'll jump and fall
asleep yeah but maybe he'll find these
like small unusual ideas that can pose
problems for Wesley I think he's uh it's
more of a carp off Casper all Vibes I'm
getting from that carp off very you know
surgical precise very like boring but
very good obviously and Kasper off just
trying to take your head off every
single game I see that with siren trying
to take your head off with the extra
weird opening choices finding the
resources magician type like uh style as
well and then Wesley just being surgical
getting a small advantage and we're
going to take this boy to the end game
until you go to sleep right so it's uh
halfway halfway half point and he Carl
was like I'm tired of this and then just
he just dropped he just failed there so
I think I see the same with siren and
Wesley today good stuff only last point
I'll button it up with is that Nihao
fell behind in both the other matches
sevian yeah lost the first game on both
days against Anish giri I don't think
he's going to be able to do that against
Wesley so and live to tell the tale so
all right we're gonna we're gonna see
how this plays out before before we do
it's time to make our picks come on
take it away Danny I'm not going to
surprise anyone I took Wesley in the
last match and I'm going to take Wesley
so against nihal here as well ultimately
I think that just that maximizing effect
that Wesley has is gonna get the job
done he hangs on those worst positions
so so well I think that resilience is
key here yep I'm also going to take
Wesley I'm going to take the experience
I believe he already knocked out maybe
the toughest opponent who was in the
field in Nakamura and that momentum is
going to carry the day I believe the
same thing I'm taking big flexley there
my man's just flexing real hard and he
definitely be of course my favorite
which was Hikaru so definitely got to go
west
I'm going to go against all you guys I'm
taking nihal it's a risky bet I'm ready
to be wrong but I think he's done
something that maybe nobody else in
history has done this he's beaten three
current or former 2800 players wow in a
single bracket tournament ding Anish and
Vladimir cranaku is also world champion
beating uh Gary Kasparov I don't know if
anyone's ever done that before maybe
maybe it has maybe we can get the stats
guys oh it's good that you're reaching
hard for these stats for 2800 stats
Bobby just showed up and he's taking it
away indeed that's a bold pick bold move
bold pit cotton we'll see if it pays off
all right that's it for us we'll see you
soon chat we'll be here after each game
of course one through game four but for
now let's bring in Levy Rosman and
Daniel neridisky to call game one of our
title match
thank you Danny fantastic pregame
discussion it is a pleasure to be
bringing you the first two games of this
cgc title match alongside the one the
only the magician International Master
Levy Rosman beautiful shirt lever you're
off to a good start yeah listen I didn't
wear the suit today uh we're getting the
shoes all cleaned up for Championship
day number two I've sent them over to
Danny wrench's room the big head honcho
he's going to be paying for it thank you
Danny love you so much great pregame
coverage and uh really appreciate that
my suits will get cleaned up I love you
too Levy I also love this title match
because we will be watching Wesley so
taking on nihal Star and could you think
of a hypier that's not really a word a
hyper cgc title match where The Winner
Takes home a cool 200 G's Levy this is
going to be epic yeah listen uh when you
say hype obviously we think about the
biggest names in chess these guys are
right up there especially as the time
control gets faster they have earned
their right to be here Wesley in a
perfect style gameplay match versus
Hikaru nihal in a back and forth slot
Fest so obviously I'm pumped to see
where we're going here I am incredibly
pumped as well now it's time for maybe
my least favorite part I like both of
these players so much but we have to
make some picks Levy I'm gonna throw the
ball to you first yeah uh listen uh in
terms of obviously deciding who's going
to win the match uh we gotta go with
Wesley on this one I said yesterday I
would pick Wesley as a favorite over
anybody in the field not named Hikaru I
mean westerday yes yesterday yes and he
took down Hikaru so there you go I got
Wesley man I'm off the ball today listen
I love knee-hal I'm a big fan but I'm
also going to have to go with Wesley
he's just a monster and in the immortal
words of Abraham Lincoln Wesley so is
Wesley so we also know that chat went
with Wesley but hey I mentioned that
Anish plays well with a chip on his
shoulder so does nihal siren yep maybe
he'll prove us all wrong and maybe he'll
prove Fabiano right there's only one way
to find out okay it's time for us to
review the format if you don't know the
format where have you been but if you're
just joining us this cgc title match is
a best of eight games Affair over today
and tomorrow the first so four and a
half points wins the match and the time
control as it has been throughout the
cgc is 15 minutes plus a two second
increment in the event of a 4-4 tie we
will once again break the tie with an
Armageddon game but we will cross that
bridge if we get there I most certainly
hope we get there Levy yeah five games
is a minimum to decide any match nine
games being the max I think here we're
looking at one that goes seven eight or
nine there's really no doubt about it
these guys are completely different
players as we heard are fantastic guys
over there in the in the hall discuss uh
we see Wesley there yeah and taking a
look at that trophy that looks pretty
good it would be nice if uh you know we
had them face to face but such such is
life right and we got the struggle to
travel in the year 2022 and all sorts of
logistical things I'm just glad we're
here I'm glad we have two amazing
players and I'm just pump for a title
match me too it's just an honor to be
covering this we got courtside seats we
see Wesley putting on his headphones
there I mean this is just awesome we
hope everyone's seat belts are fast and
tight let's take a look at their
match-up card we've got so much to
unpack here knee-haul 11 years Wesley's
Junior Levy and what jumps out of me
they haven't played a lot of
head-to-head games no they haven't many
people will read that first rap and hit
the head yeah that was one time and look
how long ago that was I mean in chess
that's like 10 life times ago that that
was their last rapid meeting now they
did play a chess.com speed chess
championship match in 2021 you know what
the score line of that one was what was
it 15 14. it literally could not get any
closer so I'm just excited to see what
happens today because these guys
actually do have some history it's not
in 15 minutes yes it's in five minute
three minute and one minute chess which
literally combined don't make 15 minutes
right that's crazy 15-4 it was it was
just so 15 14. it was super close
they're always extremely close it was
extremely close and you just saw like
Nihao came to this match in this
nail-biting finish where it came down to
one Pawn on the ninth game against the
niche giri but Wesley as we see him
getting situated there he played didn't
he just play like the perfect
anti-hikaru strategy I mean it just was
incredible to watch Wesley said himself
like in one of our interviews that you
know he's maybe a 20 percent
against Hikaru well I doubt he's a 20 in
this match it's really close we're about
to have a first move Wesley is all
smiles nihal is intense seat belts
fastened here we go the cgc title match
D4 we're 200k is underway I thought I
was guessing the move but he plays E4
wrestling with one E4 and a Petra of S8
by nihulsar and he's been all over the
map and all over the globe in terms of
his opening choices I don't think Wesley
expects this no I don't think so either
so just a friendly reminder that nihal
played Knight C6 that is on the second
move against the niche Geary and it
didn't work out super great now I'm very
curious to see what his Petrov defense
preparation is is nihal known for his
Petrov at all not particularly he's
played it against me in Blitz a couple
of times but Levy the Petrov is an
interesting history was so popular in
the early 2000s with Boris gelfand Vichy
Anand playing it religiously then there
was a bit bit of a lull and recently
Jana panchi has breathed new life into
this opening now everybody's playing it
exactly right Knight bd2 and interesting
approach Wesley choosing to delay the
movement of the C Pawn which is kind of
key right you can go C3 you can go C4 or
you cannot move it at all now we see
Knight to D6 in fighting an exchange of
light squared Bishops both guys keeping
the tension the Bishops are having a
staring contest right now because they
are both amply protected Now take me
through the game plan here for white
where's that Knight on F1 going well
this is very reminiscent of a rookie one
Berlin Wesley clearly not willing to
take too much risk in game one there are
riskier options against the Petrov he's
basically playing for a slight pull I
think this Knight is coming out to G3
you see nihal's Knight getting out to A6
that's a very flexible developing move
you could jump into B4 but more likely
is that you're going to travel to the
center to add a little bit of beef and
protection to the e-file there's a lot
that's going to go on levy on the e-file
of both players need to be ready to take
control of it when necessary I believe
I've seen youngstov Duda the very strong
Polish player as well playing this sort
of fashion and one of the most
fascinating things about the Petrov is
that if you allow the machine to
actually get spit out an evaluation
first it says all white is better yeah
and then it goes plus 0.4 and then it
goes plus 0.3 and somehow White's early
space advantage and seemingly really
decent control of the e-file is actually
not as strong as it looks you're exactly
right now listen if you have to choose
the side somebody would be crazy to
choose black here yeah I think white
does have a slight pull and you might
ask why well the queen is a little bit
more active White's the first one to the
party on the e-file that Bishop on F4 a
little bit stronger than its counterpart
but all of that belies the important
point which is that black has no
weaknesses Black's position is solid as
a rock look at that pawn chain on the
queen side everything's protecting each
other so it's not enough just to say I
have control of the e-file that wins me
the game you actually need to do
something yeah exactly right uh speaking
of which game one and it's move 12 and
nihal has spent five seconds I know it
says move now again so the openings are
once again working out in his favor
something some move order or potentially
some sort of just maybe nihal played
something that was Wesley hadn't looked
at in a while so now Wesley needs to
spend a little bit of time right Knight
A6 Knight C7 the thing is Black's moves
here are very natural now I have a
question okay as we see in the hall sort
of getting what is the meaning of life
no not well we'll get to that after this
game is over but who is the best content
creator okay Hy he's sitting right next
to me H4 1955 I was just about to draw
some arrows okay these guys are making
moves faster than I can draw my arrows I
thought white was going to start an
attack is that what he's doing is what
is that what is that all about that's an
interesting position for the bishop I
would have bet that the Knight moves
into E5 Bishop E5 is a bit of a
provocative move I don't think we're
gonna see F6 no by Neo Hall the last
thing you want to do is on Moor this
night on E6 from its anchor then why
it's night will be able to move out to
F5 so the tempting move here for for
Neil I guess is to put his own Knight on
e4 as for what Wesley is doing on E5
maybe he wants to combine this move with
Knight F5 so if we go down this path
after 94 Knight F5 I don't think is as
dangerous as it looks Levy I'm mean even
a move like Bishop F6 looks pretty solid
for black maybe there's more accurate
ways of playing there's actually no
threat on the G7 Pawn so black can make
a sort of neutral move like rookie yeah
and slowly we're just moving all the
pieces onto the file yeah look at this
oh my gosh I'm just the the word counter
of the day is one the Dania word counter
unmur I love that that's uh that one I
can actually I use context clues and yes
this position is definitely not good for
white but at least all the pieces are on
the e-file which is oh is just like
almost a little Quest you know put all
the pieces on these I never graduated
from third grade but Bishop E5 has
gotten knee-hal to think I think he's
deciding between a more concrete
approach like 94 maybe the immediate
rookie 8 should be considered now Levy
it's it's a pretty symmetrical position
I think nihal is pretty happy with the
outcome of the opening and it's hard to
make any conclusions I think the next
couple moves are going to be really
really important the move 94 does look
natural but then at the same time it
looks kinda it's just short-sighted like
where's the Knight going after that in
fact what is the Knight even doing there
when I see the move Knight to E4 I I
expect black to be playing the move F7
F5 as well to Anchor the Knight but then
you completely destabilize everything
over here and if this Knight gets booted
somehow either via exchange or the move
F2 to F3 not just you know morphing into
your own Knight you would need to move
it out of the way then white just breaks
free completely so yeah the move 94
looks nice but are we really gonna see
it I don't I don't quite understand its
merits and maybe I I discounted F6 a
little bit too early maybe F6 should be
considered if we actually play this move
on the board it may appear that after
Bishop takes D6 Bishop takes D6 Knight
F5 is dangerous but that's just a one
move threat now what's more dangerous I
think is Knight takes D5 and this is
where black pays the price for as you
said the destabilization of the e69 I
think there might even be Bishop takes
H2 and uh King takes H2 Queen takes D5
but then why can already grab some of
the center with C4 this is kind of not
the path that nihal wants to take maybe
C4 is inaccurate but I think you kind of
get the Point yeah I do get the point
and for the viewers at home who might
not be getting the point right now nihal
is going for a very long think because
the opening is over and he is not a
Petrov expert he played himself into a
position where he was going to figure it
out now that he's sitting here he's
going wait a minute this is actually a
little bit more difficult than I thought
it was I got Wesley out of his
preparation but at that level of Chess
that we are currently watching that
doesn't mean everything that doesn't
mean oh I'm gonna win the game that just
means I have a position which I may or
may not be able to equalize and then
play to its maximum value but as he's
spending four minutes here that's a
pretty significant amount of time he
might go astray right away yeah you're
making a great Point Amman made this
point yesterday in reference to Wesley's
opening choices Wesley really sticks to
what he's comfortable with nowadays you
can play a lot of stuff to equalize with
black Karo Khan Berlin Petrov all of
these openings have a really really good
reputation the menu is more vast than
it's ever been in terms of reputable
lines but it's not enough just to get
the zeros on the engine you have to get
a structure and a setup that you are
comfortable playing and that's why these
top players put such an emphasis on
typical middle game plans and ideas not
just oh I got 0.00 I'm going to make an
easy drawer you're playing Wesley so
here and Wesley is incredibly
comfortable in these symmetrical
structures he gets them from the Berlin
you get them from a lot of different
openings and he's been playing the
Petrov with white for many many years
Wesley is a natural born E4 player
that's exactly right he's played he for
the entire tournament and if you weren't
an E4 player before this match for
whatever reason then watching a niche's
games against nehal actually would have
inspired you to play E4 because nihal
was all over the place I mean it was
tough to pinpoint him but he was taking
a lot of risks listen your course is
what inspires people right right okay
well well thank you very much I don't
know I don't know about these guys but I
will absolutely take the compliment now
the only time Wesley got in trouble in
this tournament was when he was playing
E4 against Dimitri on draken the
gentleman you see on your screen is not
Dimitri and Drake and that's nehal sarin
he doesn't play those provocative
Sicilians it doesn't have the same
playing style which is what makes this
tournament so fascinating you get a lot
of different players a lot of different
styles and you'll remember Wesley played
the move d4 ultimately against Dimitri
Wesley's an E4 player played D4 because
he's like what is this guy doing he's
playing these crazy lines but here so
far nihal is still thinking you know why
you know why still thinking because he
played an opening played an opening he's
not exactly familiar with and he's going
oh God this is actually more stressful
than I thought it was this is concerning
we're talking nihal is thinking he's
been thinking now for something on the
order of four and a half minutes he
drops down to nine and a half on the
clock there is a two second increment we
have talked so many times about nihal's
ability and time pressure but maybe
after Hikaru I think Wesley is the worst
player uh to face in a time pressure
situation because he's so objective he
knows how to pose problems in virtually
every position it's not four and a half
minutes he's been thinking nearly six
times six minutes now yeah he's got nine
minutes
well the longest time he spent was 13
seconds and that was the move Knight A6
to C7 he's been thinking about six
minutes here is nearly spending half his
clock time yeah that's like a classical
game type of thing here 94 rookie gate
we've discussed all of the candidate
moves no he and yeah I I highly highly
doubt he plays Knight E4 he might play
it because he's just making sure oh he
doesn't goes for F6 and that now it
makes sense why he took so long to think
exactly F6 is is and what he was
calculating essentially was whether or
not Knight E4 was viable and I apologize
94 was viable but he's also now looking
at this and this you don't play F6
lightly because as we have discussed the
Knight on E6 is destabilized you might
say well why does that matter there's
two pieces in the way right but that is
all about to clear out because this
Knight's gonna move here this will take
this potentially now Wesley's gonna
spend some time Wesley obviously was
also looking at this move and Wesley's
calculation is more concrete for nihal
it was more about choosing between like
three or four candidate moves that all
look similar Wesley now has to get down
to the business of calculation we
already discussed Bishop takes D6 and
Knight takes D5 that's the concrete
approach if you want to take a more
positional approach and back up this is
kind of up Wesley's alley you can drop
back to G3 then I think the hall is
going to play a knight E4 yep and the
simple primitive approach here is just
to push the pawn out to C4 put pressure
on the D5 Pawn the word of the day Levy
is destabilization and that is what
white is trying to do to Black's entire
Center the moment the center starts
collapsing the fact that the Knight on
E6 is undefended the fact that the Rooks
are not connected all of these minor
factors that might not seem important
when the center is closed all of a
sudden become the defining factors of
the position by the way I just want to
do a little chess math here okay so
let's say this position appears on the
board right and this Knight captures
this bishop that's just a very
hypothetical thing okay very
hypothetical black has now two pieces
that can fight on dark squares right the
bishop fights completely on dark squares
though both of these pieces can play on
light and dark squares which means white
actually has a more uh maybe a more
inclined position to fight on the light
squares and where is that pawn standing
where is that nightstand standing right
this bishop doesn't play as prominent of
a role against two knights because
where's it going what's going on over
here you might say oh I attacked the
rook and I move it and then what yeah I
just kick you out you would and that's a
great point you would actually kill to
reposition this bishop to F7 where it
may appear more passive but actually
protects the Knight and just protects
all of these key Center squares and
guess what Wesley he took a little bit
of time he calculated Bishop takes D6
but at the end of the day he says I like
my position nehal is already getting
kind of low on time let's keep the
tension he all drops his Knight back to
C7 wow I do not like that at what is the
long-term plan here he's starting to
slide off the ledge a little bit here
right now what exactly is wrong here
yeah that's what black wants and what
does white one white one's this and
maybe some Rook move right Rook D1
rookie one or something and we're gonna
get this moment of tension in the center
and it's up to Wesley to now walk
forward and walk knee Hall down and then
well beat him up frankly that's the it's
like a boxer listen that's not easy to
do I think what nihal is saying here is
okay yes I admit that I'm slightly worse
I'm going to to go defense mode but once
black puts the Rook on E8 and he might
actually put the F Rook on it I think
most people would find the other Rook
more appealing visually but if you put
the F Rook on E8 you can then slide the
bishop back to f8 clearing all the
pieces off of the E file and you can say
my Pawn on D5 is well protected that
actually is why nehal drops his Knight
back to C7 it was to take the sting out
of the move C4 Wesley's putting pressure
nihal saying yoga you're gonna make all
the sort of nice positional moves but
when push comes to shove how are you
going to make progress and there's
rookie too by the way one of the main
ideas in positions where there's kind of
a Unstoppable Force meeting an immovable
object which is sort of what's going on
right now in the white and black
territory here in the center of the
board is just the random H Pawn
Excursion just H4 H5 H6 and who does
that benefit right does that benefit why
does that benefit benefit black if white
over extends right here just kind of
like the concepts of yeah of course
we're gonna get the Rooks yes now black
will probably
bring the other Rook but then what
yeah well of course both sides actually
have a hard time finding improving moves
but I completely agree I love this H4 H5
idea and when you're cramped what you'll
always notice is that every additional
weakness costs you a lot more you could
say well H4 weakens White's King black
doesn't have the Machinery to even come
close to attacking white skin meanwhile
if black pushes the pawn up to H5 he
creates a big hole on G6 white could
occupy that square immediate and look
how quickly things get bad yup black
plays Queen F7 boom boom and already
white is winning after C5 suddenly the
Knight on C7 is as vulnerable as ever
Knight B5 A4 disattaching the knights
and white wins the game yep so that's
what happens when you're really cramped
you just can't afford any further
weaknesses that really hamstrings you
defensively Bishop f8 is on the board by
nihal sarin will we see H4 by Wesley we
probably will this this actually is a
bit of nihal's style he's an
unpredictable guy for sure in the
opening but in uncomfortable and
unfamiliar and brand new positions like
if you got to give me five grand Masters
in the world to put in that spot I'm
gonna probably choose nihal he really
doesn't it doesn't seem like he cares
about the opening a whole lot at all and
he might play this in classical he might
play this in Rapid he doesn't F6 Knight
C7 and there's H here we go Levy wow now
there we go finally yeah we finally I
initiated it yes and I almost missed it
by the way I looked down I know it's
hard you know it's less a lot of stuff
going our eyes are on all the cameras
Rook a to d eight by five knee Hall yeah
H5 is the natural follow-up of course
and I bet a silver dollar that we see
this pretty quickly but Levy Also let's
not forget nihal's match against Sam
Sevin the way he pulled out those minus
10 positions with his King getting
Checkmate and I mean that was ridiculous
talk about magician that is not a label
that is assigned lightly that is a very
well deserved label the problem is that
Wesley so once again is Wesley so
I'm really confused what is the way to
make progress here for white okay white
plays the move H5 and by the way
Wesley's thinking uh because he's not
sure he wants to commit the pawn yeah I
suppose so I mean I would start with H5
what you're I think implying is that if
you push the pawn all the way to age six
that then the pawn could become a
serious liability after black pushes G6
the placement of Black's Bishop is then
Justified the queen on D7 does a great
job of controlling these light squares
preventing Knight F5 and you most
certainly don't want to play the move C5
too early because then you take your
foot off the gas pedal the Knight
entrenches itself on e4 and white ends
up making backward progress I'm positive
that that's what Wesley was thinking
about not whether he should play H5 he
knew he wanted to do that he's thinking
about the future what's next
now my question is are you taking on D5
is that is that where all of this is
headed are you going to take there try
to isolate upon try to jump around get
in there to F5 somehow I do think we we
are likely to see a bishop takes Knight
at some point I think Wesley's likely
going to get a two nights versus a
knight versus Bishop situation at least
to try to occupy that F5 Square will
that lead to an attack on the king
because this Pawn is restricting the
play over here or will it lead to a
focus on this Pawn or will it lead to an
infiltration in the long run onto the
queen side I don't know I really have no
idea what's coming next in this position
neither do I I just want to clarify that
94 would be jumping the gun here and I
wanted to show why this move fails it
fails maybe I mean black doesn't lose
but after Bishop C7 Queen C7 uh that
pawn on D5 is under a tremendous amount
of pressure and white is a very simple
tactic Knight takes D5 taking away the
defender then white takes on e4 now it's
just completely winning for white I
would say I mean black can take and play
Rook takes H5 all of a sudden but look
YT file control check no this is the
worst case a computer is trying
computers laughing at everything I'm
saying but you know I'm used to that I'm
used to that yeah anyways look
practically look at Queen F7 again it
all comes down to practically yeah the
players don't don't see the evil bar the
players don't see the computer so yeah
there you go the pawns under attack he's
trying to make him pay he's trying maybe
that's what Wesley was thinking about
how how does white defend the pawn here
actually do you have an answer to that
no but can the pawn be taken yeah that's
a good question so let's make a random
move for white like Bishop H2 Bishop H2
sure if the pawn is captured oh white
has the C5 right C5 C5 yeah we're back
to the C5 and Knight db5a4 but I think
this is not a very I almost called you
Wesley again I've managed to avoid it
thus far this is not a very sustainable
defensive idea I mean I'm pretty sure
the black can play a move like Rook D7
these Knights can be defended the C5
problem can be addressed and if white
loses the pawn on H5 all of a sudden we
start singing a completely different
tune that's absolutely right actually
it's quite concerning for some reason I
thought I'd just get to push my Pawn to
H5 I know stupid there I it's much
easier to push other people's pawns oh
and sacrifice other people's pieces
correct move other people's pieces yes
exactly Wesley's gonna have to
potentially sacrifice his own Pawn on H5
because as we indicated earlier H6 is
incredibly tempting Black's most
definitely not going to take on H6
Black's gonna push G6 this bishop is
such a heroic defensive piece that's
what I love about Chess yeah so great
defensive piece I'm just going to kind
of show that the audience also black
just gets a little porcupine action
going on literally every square is
covered I mean good luck yeah you're
never getting ranked defense and look at
White's Knights they used to be sitting
pretty now they have no prospects
players have spent about half their time
yeah look at the clock Wesley now he's
the one taking the long but this is this
is a this is a fantastic game one what
what more can we ask for we have totally
different styles we have totally
different ages totally different
pedigrees and tracks to this final and
we have a very tense position with even
clock time yeah and this is what great
form means you know nihal took those six
minutes after he got the slightly worse
position he found the ideal defensive
setup he put it into effect and now he's
reaping the rewards the ball is firmly
back in Wesley's Court the pawn on H5 is
hanging and Niall saying congrats you
double your Rooks on the e-file where to
from here
I actually don't know in fact I'm sort
of struggling to find the movie no I
know that procrastinating on suggesting
a move because I don't know what to play
do you force the issue on D5 do you we
already decided you don't want to shut
this all down because actually black
just immediately sees his control of the
game but what do you do can you play
Knight H4 and try to put the Knight
immediately onto F5 it doesn't feel like
you're in any position to call the shots
no you're not and the problem with
playing C takes D5 is that of course you
you don't have the C5 trick anymore so
after the trade yeah the D5 Pawn is
weaker but so is the H5 Pawn Wesley
plays A4 making sure that Queen takes H5
is impossible now black doesn't even
have the B5 square but what if nihal
reinforces the threat by bringing his
Rook up to D7 Queen takes H5 might be
the first threat that black has posed
white this entire game but it's a
serious threat indeed it's a serious
thread that was the longest that Wesley
has thought on a move thus far it took 2
minutes and 46 seconds to come up with
A4 and I got news for you A4 doesn't do
a whole lot no it's it's an improving
move it grabs space on the queen it
could also be a liability of a move you
never know you certainly can you
overextend your pawns suddenly B3 is
weak now nehal clearly reacts he doesn't
like this something so he plays A6 now
doesn't play Rook D7 I really liked Rook
D7 but I don't know why he didn't play
Rook D7 you know I thought that was a
big opportunity I think maybe nihal is
still in defensive mode we talked about
this before it's so hard to make that
psychological switch during the game to
sense the moment when you have to jump
onto the offensive Knight to H4 a big
move by Wesley G I wonder where the
Knight is going now G6 maybe a sacrifice
tonight maybe actually uh Queen takes H5
C5 we've already addressed that now how
dangerous is all of this how dangerous
is this infiltration on on the F5 Square
well I think Wesley is trying to pose
the same problem that nihal posed him a
couple moves ago what exactly does black
do how does now black improve his
position this old friend Rook D7 if
black plays the move here I don't think
this is quite as effective because after
C5 if the Knight drops back to C8 then
we can eliminate the Knight on C7 slam
the Knight down on F5 and and Levy you
get a really really concerning scenario
where the Rook from C7 can't rejoin the
e-file nobody can watch anything look at
this black is completely paralyzed 97
Knight D6 yeah that's so tragic I think
you have to send the Knight down to E4
but once again after the trade white can
play Knight EF5 F3 is a huge threat and
suddenly the Knight on e4 is
destabilized it's completely oh but
there's a crazy line here Queen takes H5
okay F3 Knight takes C5 hello
all right you want my knight Queen yeah
take it you want my knight I'm gonna I'm
gonna get everybody for it okay I think
after white takes these Knights are just
so strong and that placement of The Rook
on C7 really concerns me the fact that
it can't get back to E7 easily yeah I
think nihal just kind of I don't know he
didn't seize his moment there Rook D7
would have been a nice untangling move
but yeah now he's he's in a little bit
of pressure yeah he might be a little
bit late to the party that this might be
actually a pivotal moment you're all not
playing Rook D7 sounds like we're making
a mountain out of a mohill but this
actually could be a mountain you know is
taking his time did very well could be a
mountain could be a mountain of problems
here yeah he's down down to uh four
minutes on the clock two minutes behind
Wesley it's a substantial amount of time
obviously at this point and a lot of
questions still remain for the black
position yeah Knight H4 is such a good
practical move and yeah he has to figure
out whether he plays Knight E4
immediately actually I don't mean to cut
you off I think I think A4 was a really
good practical move I think Knight H4
was sort of expected right you know the
eyes are on the effect but A4 was an
interesting move because it did nothing
and yet did something it it like if if
nehal has plays Rook D7 after the move
A4 maybe we're having a different
conversation but somehow Wesley plays A4
and why didn't he play Knight H4 right
away why did he have to include A4 it's
another question I'm actually not sure
that's the question which is circling
around my mind something we can discuss
after the game but look at nehal's clock
down to three minutes we're still
relatively early in the middle game
nothing concrete has happened I'm
getting incredibly concerned here for
nihal's game one chances Knight H4 I
mean that is just a buzz on meat grinder
move by Wesley so I'm still so
fascinated like just just to go back
here and move we have like beautiful
artwork like what exactly was preventing
the move Knight H4 straight away it
seems like there was some sort of
underlying meta strategy yeah by the way
I think we do have a moving light board
we have whoa just to get you up to speed
nihal took on C4 and played Knight to E6
he will now fight against the white
Pawns in the center with his horses
that's a huge decision that's a huge
decision now that's not necessarily
capitulation that's not necessarily a
moral victory for why Whitney Hall is
saying is hey yes I'm giving you the
center but look at your hanging Pawns in
the center my Rooks are firmly
positioned to exploit especially the
weakness of the D4 pawn and you can
already consider tactics with Knight
takes D4 in a discovered attack now
Queen on D3 is suddenly feeling a little
bit uncomfortable and I'm not sure if
Knight F5 solves all of White's problems
let's not forget that H5 now actually is
hanging Knight H to F5 here by white is
such a it's just such a cluster of
pieces just flying all over I don't even
everything is staring at everything else
and I think in the long run the idea was
in fact C5 and to prevent this hitting
something in the center like maybe this
was just an absolute brilliant little
meta move where the move C5 now forces
the Knight back that would be incredible
if Wesley saw seat uh D takes c496 and
controlled the B5 Square twice in order
to be able to play C5 talk about
positional depth so Levy you like the
look of C5 here because it sends the
Knight back to C8 doesn't it yes as I'm
as I'm seeing there the machine is just
can we show this please yeah we
absolutely can the best move here for
black according to the computer is to
still play Knight B5 as the second best
move but Knight to E4 oh my gosh just
losing the damn thing and then Queen
takes there's Knight takes D4 which
shows you the power of nehal's idea this
is not lost for black but it's slightly
worse because white will pick up but it
didn't happen yes he played C5 did
Wesley so and nihal we can't blame him
for not having this move on his radar he
drops his Knight back there it comes
Wesley's night yes so C5 was in fact
played and the craziest thing is Knight
B5 was another idea by the computer just
losing the Knight I mean that's just
like how do you blame the guy right but
we yeah we do have live moves Knight E
to F5 played and uh I don't like this
position I don't like like it at all you
know what the terrifying thing is Knight
takes E5 doesn't have a direct tactical
refutation Wesley's just saying hey you
can take my Pawn this Pawn has done its
job I'm gonna swing the queen over to
this G-Force Square threatening a fork
on H6 and if the king slides over to h8
wait why don't I just take on C5 and
take on E8 ah after Knight C5 I don't
know I'm very let's put it on the
computer let's see if computer refutes
my entire existence totally valid DC and
then and then and then rookie 8.
never sacrifice your queen oh apparently
Queen D7 only move otherwise it's
completely winning for white but
computer says no no no you're right yeah
just Queen F3 and queen G4 and yeah
white is completely winning yeah because
if you move your knight there's there's
97 or rookie seven but I think white can
play this in a simpler Way Queen F3
let's say the Knight goes back Queen G4
and just look at all of these threats
and Levy when I wanted to to is that
here I think Knight G6 check just ends
the game on the spot you jokingly
mentioned this move you knew it would
make an appearance one day oh my gosh
yeah let's just show that line down to
the end and by the way that is what's on
the board I think we should just rewind
to the current position yes we might see
this yeah we might see this queen F3 is
a Savage Savage idea just ignore the
loss of of the pawn with the tempo Queen
to F3 and this entire game is
categorized by uh characterize not
categorized characterized by the fact
that white got the lead in development
and the easier free-flowing play now
kind of played an opening that says no I
want to restrict you and there's Queen
F3 but just look at this Precision Levy
we almost take this for granted I mean
this is just he's a scientist I mean
he's just playing with just surgical or
he's a surgeon whatever analogy you want
to make make this game one is just
amazing yeah this is tremendous stuff
here demonstrated by Wesley so and just
to tie my point together he had the
early lead in development and he all
played an opening that they're very
restricting very much come at me and I'm
going to defend and he just didn't he
just didn't defend the Right Way Wesley
finding this critical A4 idea there was
one critical move in this game one the
move that nehal just played A6 and not
Rook D7 he did not seize control of the
position when he had a chance Wesley
lulled him to sleep nehal just assumed
that Wesley has no follow-up so let me
also just make an improving move toss
the ball back into Wesley's court but
Wesley saw one step ahead that was an
amazing idea 30 seconds Now by nehal his
position is completely lost the queen is
coming to G4 Levy how can you defend
with four pieces technically five pieces
all sitting on your back rank the Knight
on C8 totally out of the game
I think it's time to administer the last
rights here for for any Hall then he
ends up taking on E2 with the queen
which is fine Queen takes and yeah Queen
g4nx basically a pre-move like you give
away everything on the queen side he
doesn't care Wesley is now up oh look
how quickly played that he like
pre-moved it he literally he literally
pre-moved it a little bit dangerous and
you all could have played Queen takes H5
yeah oh my gosh Queen D7 let's not
totally count him out we have seen crazy
comebacks by any home but somehow I'm so
pessimistic because it's Wesley so on
the opposite side of the world I was
gonna say the board he's technically on
the opposite side of the globe can you
go 96 anyway I think you can play just
throw that in there yeah Knight G6 is
just a dagger I mean ever it feels like
everything I think Queen F3 was the
dagger but this is another dagger maybe
more than one I suppose so not in a
basketball game though in the game when
you hit a shot to take a lead late in
the game there's not two daggers but I
guess if it goes to overtime afterwards
no but then the first dagger wouldn't be
a dagger because then it wouldn't have
won the game anyway back back to the
game I think you should avoid Knight H6
check and trading Queens I think if you
do that and play rookie 8
oh I won't necessarily make these moves
but black and then take on H6 and
remember the black is up two pawns so
the best case scenario for any holiday
finds a way to trade Queens he gives
away one of his minor pieces and he
takes the pawn on D4 Wesley has to go
for the kill here and look at the time
usage just professionally taking as long
as it takes and Knight G6 is slammed
down by Wesley this is all over two
seconds remaining fast to make a move
make one and he does that's it Queen H5
takes and queen H5 is me you could even
play Rook take C7 and queen H5 keeping
the Knight as an attacker guarding the
Escape score for Black's King Rook takes
E7 is a disgusting oh and he's gonna
play you just know he's gonna play Rook
takes E7 rookie seven Queen H5 and the
king is mercilessly hunted to his Doom
God the craziest thing is that after
rookie seven and queen H5 if black tries
to give away his Queen for the night
white doesn't even take the queen on h8
oh that's it takes in Queen E6 Queen E6
and I think nihal will resign it's made
in three one unbelievable game by West
that was a spectacular first game a
statement perfect game perfect game from
Wesley so from start to finish he hops
off the stage hopefully doesn't Tony
Ferguson his knee or something like in
that fourth fight against Habibi walks
out what a convincing first game by
Wesley so I mean this was not just
classical level Even If This Were a
classical game this would be a
masterpiece still to score ladies and
gentlemen is one two zero in Wesley's
favor he leads the cgc title match after
a spectacular first inaugural game I
have to say that was just tremendous he
played E4 and he wanted to see what
nihal was going to bring to the table
and what nihal brought to the table
Wesley just smashed against the wall he
said this is not gonna work I don't
think we're gonna be seeing nehal play
another Petrov for the duration of this
match because we saw the same thing in
the match against the niche giri right
but uh I think we're gonna jump in
analyze the critical moments of this
game a little bit further here because
it really came down to a tense moment in
the middle game for about four or five
moves it looked like it wasn't going to
be so smooth yeah I'm gonna fast forward
through the opening they were blitzing
out their moves we've seen this type of
position so many times white has a
slight pull that's undeniable but nihal
is hoping that his incredibly solid
structure is going to make it impossible
for Wesley to make progress very
confidently guiding his Knight over to
E6 Bishop E5 nice little move provoking
app sticks that's where it all started
Levy uh nihal weakening the E6 Square
Wesley continuing to improve C4 but
you're referencing the point after which
Nicole brightest pieces into the center
suddenly after Queen F7 Wesley's the one
who has to deal with a threat and we
started singing a different tune here we
thought that niho might even be close to
taking the upper hand that's exactly
right and then Wesley thought for his
longest think of the entire game of a
whopping two minutes and 45 seconds and
pushed this very nefarious Pawn on the
complete opposite by the way you like my
word nefarious nefarious yeah no and I
liked your earlier word but I forgot
what it was that's okay I forget
everything I say the move A4 is this you
don't really understand what exactly is
going on here but it seems to restrict
the Black Knights from ever going to B5
and you're about to make a point I
believe no I was just gonna say I think
the solution to our mystery this long
unsolved mystery why not Knight H4 first
I actually am pretty sure that it is
because after DC BC if nihal plays the
same thing he played in the game here
the move C5 loses a lot of its luster
why because the Knight has this
beautiful anchor Square on B5 why loses
the D4 upon Levy wheat can confirm this
with the engine this actually is the
reason why Wesley starts by pushing his
a pawn one that's no this is
unbelievable that's so fascinating it it
so look at Wesley's game plan here the
move A4 enables the move Knight H4 isn't
that fascinating what if what is it just
is amazing it's just amazing and it's
amazing when Wesley so handles the white
pieces in a game like this I mean I like
so two things are going through my mind
right now number one nihal got blown off
the board on both days against the niche
giri with the black pieces so I'm
thinking ah we've been here before
nothing to worry about on the other hand
Wesley so is playing out of his damn
mind he's played one bad game in this
entire event and it was the first game
against Dimitri and Drake and that was
it that was his allowance I got it out
of the way hey you got it out of the way
you got it out of your system right you
had like one bad moment and now he's
just playing spectacular chess and look
at this it's like the butterfly effect
the flapping of a butterfly on one side
of the world leads to something
ostensibly unrelated on the other that
pawn and A4 guards B5 just amazing last
chance for neho might have been 94 once
he dropped his Knight back Wesley
pounced with Fury with determination and
Knight G6 ended the game with a
checkmating attack perfect perfect
chef's kiss you name the adjective
Wesley wins game one Levy just
incredible just amazing and all I wanted
to say there was that trick to hang the
knight in the center of the board and
then win a little bit of material back
that's like vintage nihal like that's
like vintage nihal in a Blitz game oh
I'm dead lost I can never play the move
Knight C8 wouldn't you say that Knight
C8 is kind of an uncharacteristic it is
he just played Knight C8 and just
allowed the game to happen very strange
first game he's got to shake it off like
Wesley did in that first game against
and Drake and way back that seems like
ages ago at this point because that was
not the nehal we're used to seeing no
but it's an eight-game match nehal will
have the white pieces in the next game
he also lost game one two and yoshikiri
we know how impressive he is with white
there is only one way to find out but
both players are going to reset and so
will we but for more reaction on this
amazing game one let's head back to the
gameplay Hall with Danny and the Gang
take it away my friend thanks John an
amazing game an amazing call by you and
Levy you guys are crushing it Danny
wrench here alongside side of mon
Hamilton James Canty and Fabiano caruana
for the Intermezzo guys let's look at
the scores remind everybody what just
happened Wesley so strikes with the
white pieces before everyone freaks out
let's remember nihal has lost with black
to start what every single one of his
matches here at the cgc finals but
indeed Wesley does jump out to a big
lead not sure if nihal is facing the
same opponent this time so we'll see how
that goes so all right guys uh Favi kick
it over to you first there was uh some
maybe uncharacteristic play by nihal
there according to Levy with some
passive moves maybe some nerves yeah
that wasn't a good opening choice and
you know who is watching the games with
us it was the man that nihal beat on his
Fury and the one thing he said is nihal
doesn't have the openings with black
yeah to face Wesley that's going to be a
big problem for him but I just don't
understand this opening choice on any
level yeah doesn't have much experience
with it we already saw Duda loss to
Hikaru early in the early matches in
this uh bracket
in the same line like Hikaru gets a
slight advantage and increases the
pressure and in this time control it's
just not a very good opening Choice yeah
another thing is the only reason I don't
like this opening Choice Wesley played
with black recently yeah and the
sinkfield cup against Hans Neiman he
plays this line and he beats him with
black and it was exactly the same idea
B3 C4 Bishop B5 almost a carbon copy
except Wesley was on the black side and
and it was a classical game so there
were some differences there but he he
knows a lot from both sides why would
you choose a slide I don't get the
opening choice but what new hell does
have is he was able to come back many
times with the white pieces and he'll
have to do that again yeah can'ty let's
throw it to you here Wesley Wesley
played incredibly well regardless of
nihao's bad opening Choice Wesley was
dialed in there to start this thing I
mean look hey you know when you pump
like flexi flexley is bro I mean it's
going you're going to see it you're
gonna you're gonna feel it and actually
Wesley play very good chess I mean
there's nothing else to say that really
he played excellent I mean nehal tried
to get some chances there he played up
obviously the petrov's not in his uh
repertoire playing stuff he had that
again with Geary with I mean I think
psych part or some decisions in that
black opening repertoire is definitely
gonna have to be tweaked and changed
ASAP and come back in here of course we
have the white pieces in the next game
hopefully he can try to strike there but
like we said like you said before Wesley
you can't be doing that with big West
like big Flex gonna take you down you
know what I mean like he already took
Hikaru down all these other guys right
and now it's uh it's the SARS turn but
he cannot slip up again like that again
especially uh going the next game yeah
you bring up a good point like you can't
slip up against Wesley yeah that's the
thing he's going to punish those
mistakes and the thing is I feel like
Nihao sometimes needs to warm up to the
match a little bit and he starts slow
now he's had some impressive comebacks
Danny but I don't think you can rely on
that you know every single time that
you're going to be able to dig your way
out of a hole that you put yourself in
because Wesley if he jumps out with
early points in the match it might be
too much to come back from you're 100
right and we kind of set it to start our
preview those of you who've been with us
from the very beginning of course you
all have right we said I don't think
nihal can fall behind against a guy like
Wesley his style his approach he's too
accurate and so Bobby let's ask you to
talk about that right if you're nihal
okay you lost but also you've been
playing well with white regardless of
what Anish is saying out there about
your black repertoire yeah well
personally if I were down the match
right from the beginning I wouldn't feel
too confident especially against Wesley
because he's very hard to break down we
saw Hikaru try again and again until he
was so frustrated that he just couldn't
do it anymore and he he you know had to
avoid a repetition because that pressure
had built up in him it's so hard to beat
Wesley very bad start for knee Hall I
think you even mentioned before the
first game that the first thing Neil has
to do is not get behind the match
but he did now he has to do what he did
against them so beyond what he did
against Anish giri yeah which was make a
comeback with the white pieces I hope he
has some opening ideas to do so because
you can't butt your head against Berlin
like Hikaru tried so many times you need
to I see James falling asleep
so I hope that he has some like offbeat
D4 opening something to spice it up I
suspect so but we'll see whether he
wants to be the comeback kid or not
apparently he's going to have to be it
again all right well we've only
completed one game today so we are far
away from a potential comeback or
Armageddon scenario yet but yesterday
nihal Soren and Anish Geary battled in
an Armageddon battle that Robert Fabi
and myself watched outside very very
closely
apparently the winning move is F5 you
trade the pawns and then the king being
cut off is actually significant yeah
five looks good though
oh my gosh not temporarily that was an
impossible move that was a really hard
move to play I think he does because if
he plays Rook H6 to pigs
he can throw his Rook on F1 I think that
might hold F5 is a winning move in a
sense that now when he moves somewhere
yeah oh my God he found it
you can see in that moment that we knew
a niece had missed it he clearly had and
that the wheels were about to come off
but let's talk a little bit about
Armageddon follow me I'll start with you
the cgc has a format where rather than
normal rapid tiebreakers going to Blitz
and bullet we decided why decide a rapid
championship in Blitz and bullet you go
right to that Armageddon bid have you
enjoyed that part of the format what are
your thoughts about the way we've
instituted Armageddon here well
personally I love Armageddon it's
actually one of my favorite uh chess
formats and the bidding process it adds
a different element it's something that
I'm not too used to but I gave it some
thought since it was sort of important I
would have to think about you know what
I would be comfortable with playing with
the black pieces playing with the white
pieces also uh the number that I came at
is around 11 minutes 30 seconds that
would make me feel like it's balanced
whether I were playing white or black
but I see most people seem to go a bit
higher and even nehal went 14 minutes 15
seconds in that game I think he wanted
white at any cost but yeah that's a bit
that's a bit and crazy I mean 15 minutes
15 seconds what if you what if the guy
goes 1359 right knowing that you want
the white pieces so he's like I'll take
as much time as I can get and then
you're left with a one minute I mean one
minute got squandered so quickly right
ultimately that helped me how that he
had enough time to do it so maybe maybe
a smart bit in the end well yeah maybe
it's my bed of course Armageddon I like
the fact that I always like to take
black there just as the fact that you
got that too I mean you got the two
options yeah all I need is a driveway of
course to get a draw you have to play
for a win so you mean I could play for a
win I gotta drive if I find a Perpetual
it's a wrap like that's good I'm looking
for those two things so I am a big fan
of the Armageddon format also like the
time that it's not like a blitz match or
like the world championship decided on a
rapid game you know stuff like that
right so the Armageddon format here is
an amazing accident well I think what's
interesting about the format is that
nobody knows how to do it properly yet
and that's what I like about it you have
these guys who are you know the best in
the world at this thing called chat yes
and well now we've added this extra
element this extra layer suddenly the
wrong bid you might just be two three
minutes off and the bid is enough to
lose you the game or put you at a severe
disadvantage to start things off so yeah
I just like how suddenly that's that
extra layer Danny it's like another meta
game another meta game yeah and on that
note you said that people are making the
wrong bid I'm gonna give a shout out to
Daryl Mori my boy Philadelphia 76er GM
who was texting me mid bid he's like
none of these guys know the meta that's
a horrible bid that he's like he's like
I can't wait for you guys to do more of
this because he loves that kind of
analytics advanced stuff so shout out to
Daryl who's watching uh and he thinks
Grandmasters have something to learn
about these Armageddon bids it's
definitely a joy to watch regardless and
we have enjoyed our time here in Toronto
this week but one of us is from here and
that's you Iman that's right Danny uh
you know spent a lot of time in Toronto
I call it home and uh recently I was
able to check out the Madison pub which
is a great place to play chess
[Music]
hey guys welcome to the Madison meets
every Wednesday we call it the Maddie
great place for just like a hangout I
love the atmosphere casual you can like
grab a beer have some fries Crush some
noobs and chess and right now they're
running a blitz tournament that's a
great place to hang out every Wednesday
they host it right here at the Madison
and as you can see behind me we're in
full session here it's a great place a
lot of people have dropped into this
very location including Grandmaster
Hikaru Nakamura as recently as I believe
it was last week or a week before and
then guys like me also come once in a
while so it's a fun place to hang out
foreign
[Music]
looked like a lot of fun but it also
looked insanely packed is that because
they knew you were coming or is that is
the Maddie always that happening uh
honestly I'd love to take some credit
here uh Danny but it's just that
happening it it happens once a week so
you know the time you know the place and
everyone just shows up so it's a good
time but I can't take that much credit
it wasn't me Danny come on what are some
other great places to play chess in
Toronto well fabulous thing is it's not
just that right there's the pub style
but there's also like the outdoor
element right so you have some parks in
downtown Nathan Phillips Square it's a
great spot right and then you also have
chess in the park where they just pick a
different Park all across Toronto and it
kind of rotates so you see the city as
well as get some chess games in Nathan
Phillips Square we were talking about
that yeah right Nathan Phillips Square
you know I mean I love the ronto baby I
was in a hit when I got I got here and I
had a poutine right and I'm sure y'all
saw the the film there it was nice I ate
it and then passed out and it was so
good and then uh right Berlin protein
right and then I a waiter waiter
challenged me to chess he was a very
strong 1070 in fact right and we uh we
took him out so we got some footage of
that as well so lots of Chess here in
Toronto I'm loving it who won I won that
one okay I mean you know it was uh easy
despite being tired with all the
poutines nothing man I'm a Jed item I'm
saying like all right well before we
take a break let's remind you that brave
means private browsing and so much more
by default Brave blocks ads and trackers
on every page and video you visit even
on YouTube no ads means up to three
times faster page loads faster streaming
and faster playback it also means 35
percent longer battery life while saving
on mobile mobile data and internet
bandwidth for Android iOS and desktop
get the best browser for gamers
streamers and creators switch in 60
seconds at brave.com chess all right
much much more to come from day one of
the cgc title match we are off and
running and game two is right around the
the corner we look forward to lots more
fun from Toronto when we come back
subscribers stick around How brave will
nihal sarin be we got exclusive content
coming your way
[Music]
come on
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what are you doing there
nobody puts Danny in the corner
come over here
[Music]
check out chess.com's newest mobile
release for Android and iOS now with
game review
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play use
retry mistakes to get another shot at
finding missed opportunities
game review is available today on both
Android and iOS
download our app and try it yourself
I have to fight for my spot because
there are always other players other
younger players but I like I like the
game give your best see what happens hey
I just want to play some good chess
so Wesley are you excited to be here
this week yeah definitely perfect it's
good to
see all the people here in chef.com and
I'm very excited because it's the
biggest online chess tournament what are
your own internal expectations for
competing this week I really look
forward to it you know their eight games
and about my favorite tournament format
okay yeah it's interesting because you
know you don't know when you're going
home as long as you don't lose too many
games and you still got a chance how is
preparing for a rapid tournament like
cgc different from preparing for large
over-the-board events six years ago most
of the tournaments were classical but
this year we're really moving in online
also faster time controls and speeches
so you gotta be very good with very good
with the mouth and also practice makes
perfect thank you so much Wesley it's
been a pleasure having you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to Toronto and day one of
our cgc title match our players are
getting ready to compete in our second
game of the day we are playing best of
eight over today and tomorrow earlier in
the year many of you participated in our
cgc bracket challenge here's your picks
for our title match we can see that less
than one percent predicted this Wesley
nehal match up to even happen that's
crazy with 53 14 of them choosing Wesley
to win the entire thing all right
welcome everybody to the cgc title match
it's time for game two and nobody I'd
rather cover it than with my partner I
am Levy Rosman Levy what an epic game
one I'm just so excited to be here as I
said right before we went to break it's
basically the same story lines in
multiple cases we saw nihal sarin get
taken down in both games one of the last
two days well what's three right three
is the charm but does that mean that
Wesley has the upper hand moving forward
or does that mean that nihal is about to
strike back I don't know that is why we
are sitting here that is why we're about
to have a game up on our screen in a
moment I'm just excited looking to see
when he all trots out with the white
pieces well he's been trotting out all
sorts of souped-up London systems and
he's gonna have to bring his A-game
because Wesley we see him sitting
intently on the screen Wesley has most
certainly brought his A-game and he's
brought his A-game in the opening phase
as well Levy I just have a feeling that
nihal will have to produce something
very very serious let's take a quick
look at our insights card we can see
that they have very similar stats really
across the board in terms of average
accuracy a lot more of nihal's games
reach the end game phase that's kind of
I don't know if that's a bad side or a
good side pretty well I think the thing
to think about here is nihal plays a lot
more Wild Games as you can see there and
as you said his games make it to the end
games right and uh the thing about the
end game is that he's probably winning
those games as we saw yesterday against
each in scrambles in low time situations
but that last game that we just saw did
not make it to an end game and it wasn't
the Wild game it was not and it wasn't
even close to an end game but here we go
game two of the cgc title match has
kicked off and our eyes are on the
screen what are we going to get from
nihal to the surprise of the entire
world
that's crazy he's never done that people
never bring his Bishop out to F4 C4 yeah
Bishop F4 again against Geary he played
three Bishop F4 in this position of very
rare move indeed drum roll please ladies
and gentlemen why is he's thinking why
is it what did he not well E6 is such a
rare move Levy I mean come on wow so he
he's just going for a main line huh well
that's that remains to be seen there are
a couple of rare moves in this position
I've seen a check on A4 wow Catalan
system by Neo okay a Catalan he's the
first this is the first time nihal with
white hasn't played a very very clear
sideline with the war with D4 I mean
yesterday he was bringing his dark
scored Bishop out to E3 in a London I
mean that was crazy all of a sudden he's
been playing mainstream stuff in the
first two games but how confident does
he feel in these Catalan lines I don't
want to read too much into the body
language he looks frustrating he looks
fresh it's not just me yeah he like what
was he not expecting because Wesley
plays Knight F6 E6 listen he was Wesley
played E60 was surprised now Wesley
plays one of the main Catalan responses
C5 and Knight C6 this has been around
for decades now I mean Gary Kasparov was
playing this in the 80s and Niha looks
surprised again maybe he was surprised
by 5 five uh by move five C5 yes C5 or
maybe he was surprised that Wesley took
on C4 because you know nowadays black
can basically do anything here Bishop E7
Bishop B4 and so on and so forth okay we
have a lot of yeah we do let's catch
whoa our already Queens are off the
board 76 percent of nehals games reach
the end game yeah well we see why this
this is right around that same moment uh
this is 13 moves now played by Wesley in
in this theoretical line I have no idea
what's going on the Knight is on A5 that
was nihal starn's last move he's putting
pressure on the B7 Pawn he's provoking
the move B6 and that would really
justify the placement of this Catalan
Bishop this move seems to be the first
surprise of the day for Wesley
okay 985 at least makes sense right the
idea of that move is you cannot move
your light squared Bishop because I will
take your Pawn if you move your Pawn
well then I will zig and zag and get in
there and you'll have a bit of a weak
diagonal here so an interesting spot
here uh and actually apparently the best
move for black is to go here and then
the Knight will move to C4 but let's
keep in mind that's not where it was
yeah where did it come from I came from
B3 yes so that would not be a repetition
that would be a reroute and then this
bishop would be a target for various
happenings over here does white want to
trade it off potentially and a quick
note one thing you do not want to do in
the event of Bishop before is respond
with Bishop D2 might look like a good
idea to take care of your development
but here black has the highly unpleasant
move Knight C3 sticking a knight between
the Bishops yeah attacking E2 apparently
white doesn't lose the game what's funny
is that white actually could drop the
Knight back let's say to C4 and absurdly
enough Knight D1 Bishop B4 actually wins
for for white because the Knight is
trapped and The Rook is hanging but but
but black can take on E2 here and then
Evacuate the Knight back out to C3 this
is precisely what nihal wants to avoid
this is probably not going to be seen
right no it is not yeah wow you want my
Pawn so bad go ahead take it yeah go
ahead 985 I'm I'm letting you have all
you want on the queen side I'm focusing
on my development and Wesley wants to
turn this back around onihal was the one
who wanted to fight for an advantage on
the queen side Wesley says hey uh two
can play at that game and there's a
crazy idea here for white to completely
remove oop I apologize completely remove
any instability in the center create
just this situation very symmetrical
yeah and grab a pond and say I'm a pawn
up but this is the kind of player Wesley
is he will happily defend this with
black because oh yeah he doesn't
actually think there's any winning
chances for white now uh obviously you
would love to end up in a situation with
black where the Bishops are of the
opposite color the bishop has traded for
the night but uh we saw Wesley defend
with the bishop pair against Hikaru
yesterday and actually go on to win that
game yeah Wesley is totally undeterred
as you're saying by these kinds of
defensive tasks and nihal cannot just
give this game away right a quick draw
is actually a terrible result for nehal
he's got to try to put serious pressure
on Wesley wow and he doesn't take me he
doesn't take the pawn he plays Bishop D2
instead but now
because you can't go Knight C6 and you
can't go Knight C4 probably oh because
of like Rook ACA Knight gets tossed
around but there was like Bishop B5 I
mean it just looks okay Bishop D2
something about Knight takes B7 he
didn't like I think at the very least
Bishop D5 and 197 was a risk-free move
but he goes to E4 counter-attacking
black snake oh my goodness so now if
black takes the Knight on A5 then white
is going to take the Knight on D5 and
after everything settles these pawns are
not any good and white spawns most
certainly are so Hollis headed down into
that massive percentage point of end
games as you described even though we're
only on move 16 which sounds kind of
crazy but what happens if Wesley just
hear me out just for a quick second I'm
listening what if he just doesn't take
the Knight moves his knife yeah you're
allowed to do that right you don't have
to take them I know it's crazy I know
it's great relax stop with your
controversial statements I mean you're
it's one of my people doing this it's
one of my voice was that good solid use
that was excellent Wesley razor Focus
there in the words of Robert Hess and uh
oh
oh now it's now almost off the screen
there we go
moving hither and thither E4 is on the
board now levia in the Catalan you
actually often want to avoid the movie
for because it weakens the D4 pawn and
it blocks in the bishop the sort of
Rules of Engagement in this opening are
a little bit different your move Knight
D5 to B4 looks modest solid for black
the night threatening to jump into C2
forking the pawn on the rook and he
plays it it's on the board and Wesley's
got a better position than 15 moves he
does and you know what else is
concerning this Prospect of the a pawn
pushing itself forward to A4 if white
plays Knight B3 which is quite likely A5
is just a vintage Wesley move yes just
shove this Pawn down
and all of a sudden white is feeling so
uncomfortable on the side of the board
that nihal was supposed to be attacking
on and the last thing I'll say Levy I
think you'll co-sign this if you have to
take exactly that's a terrible sign you
seed the bishop pair you see the dark
Square control and here Wesley's gonna
be living the life now only black can
win this position yeah he's already
living the life he's already living
better now he just has to actually win
the game this is shocking and this is
completely again uncharacteristic uh
Forney hassar and this is now the second
game that we've seen in this match he
has deliberately gone for a candidate if
not dare I say World Championship level
type of opening what that means is in
those types of ultra Elite and
prestigious events you play The Meta as
we call it in chess there are metas in
different video games that Catalan is
the meta because you try to play 15 16
moves of theory find a small wrinkle the
same thing in the Petrov that's all been
played in the last weeks if not days if
not if not there's tournaments happening
right now in the world where these
openings are Catalan is being played at
any particular given moment at any given
moment right you see those crazy ads on
TV oh every second there's well
everything there's a Catalan played so I
don't know what's going on here I don't
know why nehal is not looking to mix it
up more and obviously hindsight is 2020
it's it's easy to say in retrospect oh
the Petrov was a bad choice and then if
he would have drawn the game we would
have been praising you know saying how
great the Petra but he didn't but but he
didn't and he's got a bad position out
of the opening and I I really feel that
stylistically this is playing right into
Wesley's hands it's playing it to his
preparation and niho has just seemed
frustrated from the very outset of this
game literally from move two that was so
weird like he was hesitant about what to
play it's like he hadn't decided it's
like he's maybe he hadn't decided that
that happens yeah I'm sure you know that
feeling and I can't blame him you're
playing Wesley you get into this he
knows everything mindset you get tilted
and whatever you tried to do to avoid
his preparation you end up having the
opposite effect and walking right into
it right and again on both days against
the nichigiri nihal showed up in the
first game and just got obliterated like
that's not an understatement he got
completely from start to finish taken
totally apart with the when he had the
black pieces the problem is for an each
he managed now managed to strike back on
both days this is hardly striking back
yeah and that has been one of the most
impressive qualities of of nihal his
level-headedness he really never gets
tilted he's so composed in every
situation but dare I say it almost seems
like he's lost his composure here in the
early going but the Silver Lining is
that white should not lose this game if
he defends very very accurately although
I don't even know if that's true I think
after A5 or Rook ac-8 it's not just an
unpleasant position practically it's an
unpleasant position objectively even the
engine isn't really optimistic about
White's chances here that's exactly
right Black's Bishops stand very very
confidently in the center of the board
Wesley stands very confidently in the
center of his frame and black is going
to play Rook ac-8 and with white what is
the only plan here for like literally
white has one plan would you agree with
me White's plan is this D5 that's it
yeah and it comes with a price tag
you're opening up diagonals for the
Bishops right what else literally what
else you cannot move this that night did
a whole dance you literally played
Knight A5 it seemed or at least I think
it came from this Square to Target that
pawn if the bishop moved and then you
didn't take it yeah I think nijo might
have underestimated the impact that
Black's Pawn majority on the queen side
has on this position and if we just go
down the alternative to A5 Rook ac-8
another problem is that white can never
really contest the C file because that
drops the A2 pawn and now Wesley does
something kind of similar to what nihal
did with E4 rather than moving this
Knight away he counter-attacks why it's
now vulnerable Knight with Bishop A4 and
after Rook DB1 The Rook infiltrates to
C2 I mean this epitomizes how
beautifully Wesley has positioned his
pieces on the queen side and guess what
I think he went down this line Rook ac-8
is on the board it's on the board and
Wesley just kind of did one of those
things where you kind of like I wasn't
exactly sure what exactly what was going
on kind of made it I don't know maybe he
just was a little uncomfortable with
what was what was happening
he spent quite a bit of time on Rook ACA
that so maybe there is a degree of
hesitancy this does happen imagine if at
some point in this game Wesley goes wait
a minute I don't have to equalize with
black I can actually play for a win
suddenly you're getting in your own head
like well I could be up two two nothing
yeah I just went with black and suddenly
in trying to win the game you screw
things up but we're far from that we're
at least 20 minutes away for likely from
some conclusion to this game so let's
not get ahead of ourselves I see nothing
else than for white to try to at some
point play the move D5 and I'm not even
sure you could do that anymore yeah D5
just comes with too Hefty of a price tag
at this point if you play D5 uh after e
d e d I'm not sure exactly what there's
so many different threads okay Bishop F6
is not quite possible that's why A5 is
such a nice move it defends the Knight
with a pawn but you could play a simple
move like Bishop B7 to D6 right simple
stabilize the position and to your
earlier Point Levy I think it is very
important for Wesley not to jump jump
the gun here and to remind himself that
if nehal does a good job and makes a
draw that's still an excellent result
for Wesley given how he's been playing
with white so I wouldn't put too much
pressure on yourself if you're Wesley so
and I don't think he is he doesn't need
me to say that I mean his psychological
mindset is is amazing it's among the
best absolutely right and again we are
not getting ahead of ourselves too much
here there's still plenty of Chess left
to be played but this is a surprising
thing because nihal has changed the
style for the first time in the event
that's what it feels like and he's done
it in the title match that's not what
you do that you do it in the regular
season trip to the playoffs you know
what you're gonna do you stick to the
best game plan you have and it's worked
thus far so I don't know is it the first
cattle and we'll see if it's the last
Catalan we'll see he had an opportunity
to play this bishop before move like he
did against the nichigiri and then mix
things up but he just decided not to do
it he decided not to do it and
conversely I mentioned Wesley's
psychological mindset right now Niha has
to enter defense mode he needs to pull
out the draw here and he needs to not
think about the fact that oh I'm giving
up white because if he loses and goes
down to zero obviously the match is not
over but that is a total disaster at
least with the draw he's very much still
in Striking Distance so it's important
if your knee-hall not to make this into
more of a crisis than it is and I think
that's precisely what he's doing I think
D5 is a great start it's a great start
but we have talked about you could just
take you can play Knight C2 by black you
can play Bishop D6 but at least he's
trying to do something and we see from
Wesley's time management just general
facial expression that he's not exactly
sure what to do here he might sense the
position is equal he might sense that
maybe he's got some more activity maybe
he's slightly better but you have to
make moves you can't just sit here and
hit the pause button say I'm better so
let's end the game it's not how it works
yeah and I think he will start with he
takes D5 I don't really see any risk of
making this move you could kick the can
down the road one move and then you
could start deciding but the problem is
e takes D5 actually opens up even more
opportunities it opens up the
possibility of Bishop G4 this bishop
could move to F5 you pointed out Knight
C2 so a lot of moving Parts here and
Wesley has to figure out how to put the
puzzle pieces together and he puts them
together with a night Sally 2c2 now the
Knight is now attacking the road The
Rook of course goes to B1 because if it
went to C1 it would be attacked by the
dark squared Bishop now what now what
and if only we had a qualified player to
answer that question oh wait a second as
this game gets underway we have a very
special guest let us bring in the 2022
US champion Grand Master Fabiano caruana
to join us Fabi thank you so much for
coming to the studio thank you it's my
pleasure to be here with you guys all
right Fabi there's so much to unpack
Wesley's leading by a point but let's
jump right into this end game what do
you make of nehal's opening choice and
what do you make of Wesley's winning
chances in this position I think the
opening Choice was a disaster to put it
mildly I think maybe nihals was
expecting a different line of the
catalog that Wesley would play maybe the
more solid lines that Hikaru tends to
play with Bishop E7 and sacrificing upon
on the queen side as we saw him play
against Duda earlier on in the
tournament but yeah black just got a
better position straight from the
opening of comfort Wesley knows it well
he's played this line I I mean I know
from experience because in 2017 I played
the Catalan and he played the C5 line
against me and yeah overall very very
good opening outcome for Wesley why do
you think nihal was so hesitant even on
move three four five did you see that he
kind of looked already frustrated was it
do you think it's just that move C5 and
maybe even the early capture on C4 I
think that C5 came as a surprise I'm not
sure exactly why it was such a surprise
maybe he was looking at the recent
opening tree and saw Wesley's playing
other lines more more frequently but
still you have to suspect that Wesley
he's capable of going for this line he's
done it before and uh in general he's a
player who if he knows you know he knows
Theory very well he's ready to jump
around a little bit not he generally
keeps his stable repertoire but in some
places and especially the Catalan he is
ready to go in a different direction
maybe he was looking at
um like in the grand chess tour in uh
Bucharest I think it was I was playing
the Catalan I was thinking that Wesley
would go for the classical lines and he
did but he was still trying to surprise
me so when I think of Wesley and the
Catalan I think he's going to try to
jump around a bit because it's not his
most uh Pleasant opening he's actually
said this himself that he doesn't like
when people go for this opening so maybe
he thinks I need to jump around a bit to
avoid preparation
let's take a look at the position is it
damage control right now for nihal or do
you still kind of try to stabilize the
position are you trying to kill off the
game and just really hoping you get a
drawing by the way how do you do it like
if you're playing with black here what's
the next step to taking over this game
well
at this point we're already talking
about black plane for an advantage I
think he has a very safe move here
Knight to B4 to me it looks like that
forces white to recapture and then black
takes and black has the bishop pair
white might you know find a way to draw
his position because material starts to
get limited maybe Knight D4 to C6 but uh
yeah maybe Knight C6 here and black
can't win a pawn because of tactics at
least immediately but again black has a
bishop pair d-pawn is solidly blockaded
for the moment there's like Bishops
maybe bishop C6 is probably also a draw
but uh yeah I don't think that white
really plays for Advantage but nihal at
this point today I think he really needs
to end the day with minus one 50 would
be great but at least make sure it
doesn't go to minus two and he'll still
have a shot tomorrow so he just has to
make sure not to lose the game now
Wesley's thinking about how to increase
the pressure there's like moves like
Bishop G4 there's Knight to A3 there's
you know some moves which are more
ambitious but also might involve an
element of risk for black and from
Wesley's tournament point of view uh
match point of view it makes sense to
just play Knight before trade-off pieces
and go for a solid position yeah I agree
completely yeah yeah no that I was gonna
say like you can play Bishop G4 and
basically say I'm I'm now playing for a
win but the more you see Wesley spending
the time here what do you think goes
into that because some of these moves
look relatively natural right but he's
very frequently now spending one and a
half minutes two minutes on his moves
and does he look comfortable to you I
mean he kind of looks great like really
focused and not exactly just exuding
massive amounts of confidence but he
just seems locked in from his body
posture his Expressions he doesn't he
looks tense he doesn't look comfortable
but I said this before I don't think we
can really read into Bible yeah we're
generally speaking not very good at
doing that we think that you know
something means something and it
actually means nothing at all and
especially with Wesley sometimes I've
seen him shake his head a little bit and
you think that means that he's in a bad
position but then you see oh he's
actually winning so it doesn't
necessarily mean anything that he looks
intense he might just be very
concentrated I think that he realizes
he's a bit better and he can play
solidly here
I would say since he's getting a bit
lower on time he might tend towards that
but he plays a very ambitious move
Bishop to G4 wow that's the Rook the
rook's probably going to move down to C1
and then he's gonna have another
decision to make whether to drop the
Knight back to B4 kind of similar to
what you mentioned earlier Fabi or to
play the weird looking move Knight A3
obviously that hits the Rook on B1 we
could get a trade of all uh four of the
Rooks who is that going to favor
I think that in my favorite black
because of a very concrete line and we
start with Rook D to C1 that is the most
logical 983 Rook C8 Rook C8 Rook C1 if
white goes for this can black simply
take and play Bishop to F3 I'm wondering
if that Corrals upon on D5 oh wow and
forces white to make a very sad Choice
like Bishop takes A3 official takes A3
Bishop C4 and that black can even
consider B5 to to go to a purely
technical small Advantage for black
position or play King f8 E7 D6 try to
slowly get that but there's id4 white
still has White's still in the game but
black is just slightly better it's a
very clear Advantage so this is
probably what Wesley is trying to go for
yeah I could totally see him squeezing
out a win in this kind of end game like
this type of position is a nightmare to
have against Wesley okay Rook dc1 has
been played and accompanied with a draw
for which Wesley has accepted wow that's
an interesting decision
Fabby what do you make of that I was not
expecting that that totally had a left
deal maybe the time situation played a
role yeah but in that case why not play
night before because there you're just a
bit better uh but okay draw overall good
result for Wesley I mean we can discuss
whether or not he should have played on
a little bit longer I think we see like
a look of disappointment and maybe that
means that he was expecting to have more
of an advantage and then he had to
settle for uh you know thinking that
he's not actually that much better and
he just goes for a draw uh
I don't know if he's disappointed
overall with this result or if he's
happy to have made a very stable draw
with Blackberry he was never in danger
he's sitting there and still analyzing
right so he's still looking at the he's
looking at the board and going could I
have played a little bit more
ambitiously it's fascinating that after
such a dominant performance in game one
and such a stable and nearly Flawless
performance against Hikaru he's still
got some degree of hesitation like man
man maybe I should have played on you
know a little bit of indecision but as
we go to the scorecards here it's one
and a half to half he's doing quite well
in two games right yeah he's doing great
from a match strategy perspective a draw
with the blank pieces is an excellent
result he leads one and a half half Fabi
we're sorry that the game ended so
quickly but we greatly appreciate your
Insight it really is an honor thank you
for joining us in the studio thank you
it was a pleasure being here and I'll
see everyone else back at the host step
indeed you will be covering games three
and four with the great Robert Hess very
soon okay there isn't all that much to
talk about in this game but there were a
couple of surprises in the opening
whatever nihal sarin does he has to
remodel the house of his openings he's
gonna have to make serious changes in
order to get on the same level as Wesley
Fabby called the Catalan a disaster Levy
I don't think he was overstating the
case at all it was a disaster yeah I
think so moving forward I think if nihal
plays a main line he needs to play
Knight C3 do you agree I feel like
nowadays forcing the nimso Indian is
actually becoming more trendy we used to
stop doing this but you can play some E3
Bishop D2 line you can keep a lot of
pieces on the board don't go into the
main lines I bet the next time Niall
plays white we're getting the we're
getting the NIMS of Indian that's just
gonna be my pick I know we can't pick
openings but we're picking the players
to win the match uh the Catalan was
catastrophe I mean that was it was not
good and his time is ticking and I
thought Fabi had a couple of great
points on what it is that niho might
have been expecting I think that he
might have expected one of the trendy
lines I mean everybody's playing this D
takes C4 and B5 line nowadays right
which Hikaru has played but let's not
lose sight of the fact the black has
seven or eight reputable lines against
the Catalan and it's not one of those
openings that you necessarily always
have to have the same response against
Wesley chooses A Very Old Line C5 and
Knight C6 here there's two moves there's
the immediate dc5 which Hall played in
the move 95 is an alternative that has a
little bit more of an edge to it nihal
goes for the end game this is all very
standard fare black gives away the pawn
in order to ruin white spawn structure
and the first surprise of the game for
either side they're continued blitzing
out their moves a trade of knights white
fixes his spawn structure and this move
985 right very ingenious Levy you're
trying to provoke a weakness but I love
the way that Wesley responded this just
shows what his form looks like and has
looked like ever since game one against
on Dragon that's exactly right and here
I was just so puzzled because Knight A5
seemingly prevents the light squared
Bishop from moving because you're gonna
take the pawn so Knight F5 prevented the
light squared Bishop from moving because
you're gonna take the pawn and then the
bishop moved and then you didn't take it
and then you didn't take the pawn and
yeah I mean obviously he was afraid of
something like this bishop A4 but then
why play Knight A5 I just exactly why
play right the only thing's confused the
only consistent thing was the
inconsistency he allowed Wesley to push
his Knight away the Knight dropped into
before The Rook to C8 Wesley firmly in
control but ultimately the decision to
accept to draw in this position
solidifying his one point lead he will
have the white pieces in game three
nehal has a lot of work to do absolutely
a lot of work to do that was a complete
nightmare I think he's gonna play D4 C4
I think he's going to play Knight C3 and
force Wesley so to play the name so
Indian it's more forcing there's more
lines more opportunity to keep the
pieces on the board in catalans you can
play 10 15 moves of theory with black
and the game is just dead and that's
exactly what happened there with Wesley
this is looking like an uphill battle
for nihal sarin it most certainly is
especially since he'll have the black
pieces he will have to make serious
opening changes it's been a pleasure
bringing you the first two games and now
for more reactions and insights let's
let's toss it back to Danny and the Gang
Danny take it away
thank you Dania let's let's quickly go
around the horn with intros so we can
dive into it I'm on Hamilton is here
Danny wrench James Canty and Fabiano
caruana guys we're going to bring up the
scores here just to show everybody who
might be tuning in what the results are
Wesley so wins game one but then unlike
all of his other matches Nihao Saran not
able to bounce back with a quick rebound
Victory he draws the second game with
white and in a game that if anyone could
have pushed toward the end guys it was
probably Wesley and I want to throw to
you Fabi because what's interesting is
everyone obviously painting The
Narrative right now nihow is in trouble
and for good reason right Wesley one
draws easily with black but there was a
moment there where it turned around I
was like is Wesley gonna bring the
hammer down because he took the draw
instantly the moment Nihao offered I
wonder if maybe he'll regret that a
little bit because he was pushing a
little bit there I think nihal is a bit
relieved yeah that's my point because he
was on the back for the entire game
opening just didn't go well he looked
upset from the start of the game like
Wesley had surprised him a little bit
I think for him the most important thing
is that he ends the day not on a
disaster not minus two and he's able to
reassess his openings tomorrow and
potentially find some ideas because
right now he's out of ideas no openings
no way to pose a problem to Wesley which
is really going to be a problem you need
something in the opening to at least get
a game against against Ani she showed
that you know Bishop F4 early sideline
those uh those lines with G3 B3 where he
was trying to find some some slight pull
some slight way to to press on each here
and there and he was able to do that
very effectively today so far he's just
getting worse with black horse with
white he needs to reassess does need to
reassess what can he do to turn this
around a month well the thing about this
match so far is that you can easily look
back on the moment we just saw and say
oh that was a great call by Wesley or
that mistake based on how the match
turns towards right in hindsight but
right now you know Fabi alluded to it he
needs to check those openings Niha with
the white pieces that's where he's been
recovering in these matches yes right
but when they the white pieces don't go
your way then suddenly you're back with
the black pieces against Wesley so and
you know if you get tough positions with
the black pieces dating and you're not
putting pressure with white at all yeah
you have no chance in this match so he's
got to fix it with the white pieces he
certainly can't have a disaster I like
Bobby's point that even though he lost
the first game at this point he might
even prefer just getting to the next day
as long as he doesn't lose anymore so
what would you do if you were knee house
coach he's going to get black for the
second time we saw what happened with
the Petrov disaster game one what are
you telling the youngster I first saw a
little youngster we're going to play
what we know the best whatever you know
the best you need to just bring it out
now because Wesley is not anybody to
play around with we stopped the bleeding
so that's good we didn't lose two in a
row make this a whole disaster show so a
lot of times you need that half point to
just at least hard I breathe reset and
then you know Wesley's doing great I
mean wins the first game with white and
then uh drawing with black that's a high
level chest that's how it's supposed to
be done and now Niha is about to go in
here you know with the white women with
the black pieces and trying to do his
thing so it's gonna be tough for him I
think you know battle bro for for
someone who's been accused of maybe
adding drama where it's not needed at
times guilty of that I do want to say
though again obviously right now totally
the ball is in Wesley's Court he now
gets white again but it ended so fast we
all like threw on our microphones and
ran in here because I was just saying
out there in our live TV remember I'm
like Wesley has chances to win his black
so nihal saved a game against Savion and
we said in that moment Fabi we said if
he comes back in this match we're going
to remember this game where he held this
draw seven was winning
if Nihao wins next Wesley's going to be
looking back at some of these games
maybe with regret opportunities where he
could have pushed and didn't I wouldn't
put so much weight on this game just yet
because it wasn't a decisive Advantage
it was a star Advantage he could
oppressed I think he should have and
yeah it sometimes small things decide to
match right yes we might look back on it
as something that Wesley should have
done better but at the moment I wouldn't
really put too much weight on that okay
I like what James said about what nihal
should should do which is you know do
what you know best because Wesley is a
player with Superior Superior positional
understanding he has experience he's
played chess for so much longer against
top players so nihal has to get the game
into positions that he knows not like
the sort of Catalan stuff which he's
trying to surprise him but he doesn't
know too well as as this game uh
perfectly showed he needs to do what
he's comfortable with yeah all right
well good stuff there it remains to be
seen whether Nihao can turn things
around against Wesley so but as we know
nihal sarn did defeat Anish giri in the
semi-finals to make it to the
championship match despite the loss Gary
had a great run at the cgc and perhaps
it was because he uh spent some time
with you James you know the drip
recognized drip you know what I'm saying
so of course it is man roll the tape man
[Music]
all right and we're here with the Mr The
Fabulous super Geo on this Gary man how
are you good thank you good man good
look at him first we got to do a drip
Shack look at the drip check the drip
okay show them the socks one time show
them the socks bro
look at it you see the lace game with it
okay taking those super GM drip for my
Niche Geary himself okay all right so I
have a question for you Halloween was
Monday what scares you the most spiders
no not and insects no it's not snowing
but uh cute what was the most of
interesting you've done I mean I went
like Mountain skiing a lot of times but
I don't honestly think it's that
adventurous like if you tell me like you
know you I don't know you become a
suggested winner if you go bungee
jumping okay I'll do it right pre-game
rituals I have this playlist called like
um
you know you've got these soundtracks
yeah like of this epic movies yeah bad
boy you've got this uh Inception type
you know the Dark Knight Rises I tried
that didn't really work so
how do you handle high stakes pressure
200k on the line big fella that's a lot
of money I honestly like you don't think
about money so much yeah I think
nowadays with like the bank accounts who
are transfers and all that you don't
really get the feel like I mentioned if
you had like a like you would have to
pack all these dollar bills into your
bag from every tournament you know like
you want to buy like I don't know a car
and you just come with these big bags
yeah okay put it down and all right well
thanks uh so much for being with us
today all right and congrats and good
luck to you in uh cgc thank you
foreign
[Music]
you know they say you look good you feel
good you feel good you play good that's
right you look good I feel good you play
good playing good how much uh how much
you think Gary like comes to play
because of the mindset he gets in when
he's dressing dresses nice in fact I
mean look you can just tell the haircut
would be perfect I mean the glasses be I
don't know what he does or who is his
like stylist you know what I'm saying
like we got to get that we got to get
this 2800 level drip from uh from Gary
what'd you think of Gary's performance
in the cgc and the the path he had to
face to get here well the funny thing is
that before this we were discussing
brackets yeah like what's the best way
to to make a perfect bracket and Anish
is out there and I'm trying to reveal
the things that Niche was saying yeah
like it's like that charge like how to
how to find the perfect recipe yeah and
I think he said it himself yeah that he
was happy with his bracket yeah I think
he thinks strategically about these
things who are the players that he
performs better against who are the
players that he struggles with and he
played some of the guys who he
outclasses yeah and then he faced came
over job of yeah and this was a pure 50
50 match in my point of view taymores is
so strong and so successful in these uh
online knockout formats so that was a
pure 50 50 match it even went to
Armageddon right it was as close a match
as you could get yeah and after he
overcame that I think he was very happy
but mihal such a difficult opponent for
anyone I mean that was also a close one
we have to say Anish was a whisker away
from winning that I mean it was like
just one thing changes and then we have
a different finalist but that's that's
what happens in these uh types of
formats you have you have these like
last second clutch moments well a niche
dress as well but I know he has a chest
bra hoodie that he hasn't been wearing
are you gonna say something about that
yeah you know what Danny I think we got
to get that sponsorship number up to one
that you know as at that Geary level
yeah we shouldn't yeah we'll work on
that on the test bra end of things but
uh what can we say Danny the guy's
looking good playing good yeah and uh as
Fabi mentioned he could have easily been
in the finals yeah chess bro hoodies I
got a couple in the back too there you
go yeah I don't have any I'm getting one
today they give me they give me grief
for not giving them enough chests and I
still don't have a chest bra hoodie we
have one that actually fits can't you
yeah I think yeah
all right but we've had a great time
this week
be honest have you really had a good
time all week
what why it well you know it's just I've
heard some things and that's not what I
was told
[Music]
go away
so Robert bucknelli yeah loves I love I
love cannoli too can't can't even
describe how much that wants them
Danny what are you doing there
nobody puts Danny in the corner
come over here
well you know this this was all improv
right
I mean the cannoli thing that was all on
Robert I wish I could take credit I do
love cannoli though how about you for
those who didn't listen to what Fabiano
said roll the tape again it was
hilarious probably ad live in the canoe
I almost cracked up when I heard him
saying it almost ruined the whole skip
but for those who don't know we threw
that together and like literally five
minutes and I hurt my hip Danny it's
just nice to see you included you know
right like it's right your happiness
genuinely makes me feel happy I heard
they're even letting you maybe back in
the commentary Boots the promotion
they're letting this uh this guy throw a
few pieces around from time to time I
might get back in there again yeah all
right well before we take a quick break
a quick reminder the SEC is back with
these confirmed 14 players the main
event as we've been telling you begins
Monday November 21st with participants
that include Magnus Arjun Hikaru Yan
favi's here we got a niche out there
hanging out he'll be in the tournament
all all these players will be trying to
earn their way through to get a hundred
thousand dollars and remember that two
people will also be qualifying their way
in it's the most exciting speed Chess
Championship to date type SCC use the
command in chat for more all right much
more to come from day two of the cgc
championship finals as we push towards
game three and each of our final matches
here twitch subscribers we have plenty
of exclusive content for you during the
break
do not miss it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
we're at the chess.com Global
championship in belgrad with our
finalist Grand Master nihal tsar and
first of all congratulations a very
tense day thank you I understand it was
not your first Armageddon bid you bid 14
minutes and 15 seconds that tells the
world that you wanted to play White is
that right so throughout this match I
was I was a bit unsure with black all
the time that it's better to have white
and try something although I was not
really happy with the opening it just
ended well hey you had rook in two
versus rook and one did you feel like
you had good practical chances there uh
actually no so when it started I went
for this five versus four I thought then
I had good chances and I think I traded
to the stewardesses one a bit too fast
only when he played this King G6 he just
allowed me to get Rook F6 and King up
for free I realized or I thought I'm
winning and only after I played F5 I was
completely sure okay so you know you're
playing Wesley in the finals what are
your thoughts going into that match will
be an interesting match and I just uh as
usual I just hope to play my best best
chess and put up a good fight
thank you
Alex you told me if I came to Belgrade
I'd get a game in like five seconds I've
been sitting here forever
oh what's that oh pashka pressure I
didn't see you down there you got to
speak up when you won a game okay let's
get peska some phone books here Alex and
then we'll get a game in the bar
how often do you get recognized on the
street if I come to Manhattan and walk
around for an hour I'll probably get
recognized yeah it's pretty crazy okay
well we're gonna we're gonna find that
out right now hi sir uh for a dollar do
you know who this is I don't know I'm
gonna get some musicians okay okay
pretty good guess he is an artist okay
he's an artist who plays a game what
game would he play the game of Kings
don't know it okay hi sir do you know
who this is for a dollar negative
negative okay cool good talk though
you know who I am for a dog oh my God
you know this is of course love it okay
dude what I think two dollars are you
seriously yeah hey do you know who this
is for a dollar yes who is it dude
that's Levy yeah totally Rosman that's
right there you go for ten dollars you
know who I am
okay
I am the chess.com guy but do you know
who this is
okay here's a dollar for knowing who I
was for a dollar do you know who this is
dude Jake dude it's Jake no it's close
though keep guessing Tommy actor actor
okay yeah yeah what type of acting
um comedy comedy okay really yeah not
really but I was like magicians oh yeah
that's the third magician we've got so
thank you this is great it's the shirt
it's the shirt right it's got to be the
shirt okay hi for a dollar do you know
who this is
look closely it's a chess player that's
right who is he Levy you want a dollar
okay thanks man good job he got it and I
I could tell you knew you were acting
disinterested but I saw you I see the
chest in you
side
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Toronto and our coverage
of day one of the cgc title match more
with Wesley so and nihal sarin in just a
moment as our players get ready in
Toronto and Serbia well we are here in
the studio I am Grand Master Robert Hess
and alongside me is the United States
chess champion The Grandmaster the one
and only Fabiana karwana Fabi how you
doing today it's good to be back here
with you Robert yeah I kind of missed
you a little bit me too well I think
that one player who is uh looking to get
back into this match is nihal sarin
because through two games Fabi Wesley so
jumped out to that great first game with
a victory and in game two it was a draw
so we currently sit at one half to half
in Wesley's favor what does nihal sarin
have to do to turn this match around
well I think it's going to be a tough
road for him I mean he already showed
that he's vulnerable with black and he's
struggling with the white pieces to find
any sort of advantage or even to to
equalize he was in serious trouble in
that second game as well so openings are
gonna be a big problem I wonder if he'll
will have some other surprises in store
for Wesley I think right now the most
important thing for him is to play
solidly with black to try to at least
hold a solid draw and you know slowly
inch back his way into the match yeah if
he wants to take home that trophy that
we just saw there he's going to take
down the man we see on camera Wesley so
who has been locked in throughout the
entirety of the cgc and nihal sarin he
has had an impressive road to I would
say Toronto but he's playing from Serbia
but to this championship match because
nihal sarin as as we look at his player
card he took down some huge names even
in the round of 64. Ralph mahmetov is no
slouch and it only got more impressive
from there yeah as we said before he he
beat kramnik he beat ding I mean this is
amazing like nobody in the world would
not be proud of the path that he took to
get to this final and I think we're all
proud of him for never making a draw in
the Berlin in those 94 rapid games and
Counting he will not do that he is a
fighting player and he's gonna have to
give his all in this game because if he
gets the black pieces in game three
Wesley so has been locked in determined
he beat Hikaru Nakamura and for some
that would be all right I want it no
he's gonna win it over the board at
least that's his hope and Fabiano's we
get into game three we see nihal sarin
once more go to an offbeat opening this
time the modern defense early Bishop G7
so striking toward the center with the
piece is but white with D4 and E4 here
this is just looking good to start with
for Wesley yeah this is a very risky
choice
I don't know if I hate it yet that nihal
chose this opening we saw that the
Petrov he's trying to play some very
solid openings it wasn't working out for
him it still shows that he doesn't
really have openings to rely on he's
trying to jump and find some place that
he's
sort of comfortable in at least in these
pure kind of positions against Anish he
got Chances with black he even was able
to get an advantage in a few games
although when he repeated the second
time that wasn't the right approach and
then he ran into some massive
preparation still this is very risky
because you're accepting a bad position
early on at least a rather dubious one
against Wesley and we saw when when
Hikaru played the dubious line against
Wesley in that must win game that Hikaru
uh had to win to get back into the match
you know Wesley just was crushing him
from the opening uh Wesley is not afraid
to go for aggressive stuff like H4 H5 or
F4 right from the right out of the Gates
Right pushing these pawns forward is an
option for Wesley just throwing them all
up the board trying to challenge this
Pawn on G6 Force up to G5 and as you
said F4 could follow but the good news
for Wesley is he played a game just like
this yesterday as you mentioned but for
nihal you know sometimes when you know
when Wesley played this against a card
okay nobody's gonna do this against me
again at such a good position and it's
weird maybe he's catching Wesley by
surprise by playing into a position he
just had yesterday there's something
counterintuitive about that yeah it is a
very risky choice not something that I
would have done with the black pieces I
would have thought the main thing is
just to draw the game play something
that rely on something that you know
well uh as James Kennedy said you know
no play what you know best but instead
he's going for a Sharp fight I don't
know is he hoping to get winning chests
as well as well does he already think
it's a it's in a place where he needs to
get winning Chances with both colors I
would think it's still too early for
that but this is a very combative choice
I mean black is going for C5 that's
clear that's where his counter play uh
lies the problem is that you know white
has the giant space advantage and the
levers let's say on the king side to
play G4 and then either G5 or H5
depending on the situation so
yeah it's it's a very sharp opening
choice but we could see a disaster for
nehal because it is also comes with a
high degree of risk well let me ask you
something when you're playing Wesley so
let's take the person into account do
you think this is a good choice by Neil
because he played a Petrov he played
sort of a main line and Wesley punished
him for that so playing against somebody
as principal as Wesley so taking him out
of theoretical Waters is that
potentially a good decision well from my
own experience I when I wasn't a must
win with black against Wesley in a match
two years ago I played a sort of very
very offbeat King's Indian type of thing
it's very different from this of course
but still the same general idea that you
take a space disadvantage with the black
pieces but you have a lot of latent
potential the Bishops on B7 and G7
firing down across the board and if
Blackwater gets C5 here and you know
white can't answer it comfortably then
black gets a lot of counter play against
that King because the White's King on
the queen side also not Totally Secure
black skin is of course in the center
you know definitely a weakness for black
and if it goes to King side it's not
even clear how it would get there
because H6 is falling if black were ever
to move that Rook from h8 so this is a
tale of two weak Kings okay I like the
way you put that that's quite poetic you
should become a writer someday yeah I
could write write a book I saw a tale of
oh give me some ideas there I think you
just had the book title you don't need
to change anything you're perfect the
way you are and C5 hasn't played your
chest analysis on point the bishop on G7
is about to be opened up and this is a
critical moment because I was about to
say when the pawn d4s is put under
attack you're tempted to move it to
capture and here with this bishop open
there could even be a timely Bishop
takes C3 which is exactly why
um Wesley put his Knight on E2 covering
the Knight on C3 developing his piece
can put a bishop on D4 at some point and
still has the flexibility of pushing the
spawn in G4 you know if white plays
Knight D4 which I think is Wesley's plan
with his last move Knight G2 E2 are we
seeing some sort of like delayed Dragon
dorf it looks like that's what we black
has the dragon structure on the king
side B7 is typical of the Dragon dwarf
and the Knight on coming to D4 it looks
exactly like that opening which is funny
when's the last time you saw dragondorf
at the top level well I guess that felt
like a personal insult because I like
playing the dragon dwarf at least online
sorry about that no it's okay we're
gonna have this ongoing feud but Wesley
so and nihals aren't on camera and
Knight D4 is an option the last one
played Knight back to D7 I think that
was a good choice by nehal he's
rerouting that Knight to E5 and C4 he
wanted to go to B6 but Knight D5 takes
that out of blast control and also makes
it harder to move this Knight on D7 so
Fabi is it time for Neil to develop this
knight from G8 to F6 you made this great
point that black cannot Castle let's say
black at a free turn you can't Castle
because H6 is hanging so with all this
you know gameplay
on the board here I still feel like it's
nehal who's struggling to find the exact
plan
yeah I think that White's moves are very
natural and harmonious the bishop might
go to D4 the knight from E2 might go to
C3 replacing the other night that went
into the center to potentially change
the structure white would be happy if at
some point Black's cap black captures on
D5 because that part on D5 it not only
restricts the bishop on B7 it makes the
E7 Pawn a weak Pawn on open file a
backwards Pawn let's say but instead
Wesley decides to trade pieces which is
also very decent strategy and after
Knight takes up six which is the only
logical move why we'll probably play
Knight to C3 but Knight to D4 also an
option I like the bishop on E3 because
it stops black from gasoline and that
King on E8 it wants to get out of the
center you're not going to get a good
position long term if your king just
stays there forever because it's always
in danger of like let's say white plays
E5 at some moment or sacrifices a piece
on B5 that King might get into danger
one day because it's stuck in the center
and if you Castle short then you just
drop H6 so how does black respond if
white simply plays Knight to C3 here
great question I don't have the answer
but I do like nihal's clock mention wow
big move here H5 by Wesley so he is
sacrificing a pawn and can be captured
with the Knight but as soon as his
Knight caps upon in comes from G2 to G4
to kick that Knight right back to F6 the
H6 Pawn will be loose in many positions
and was Wesley getting impatient here
because H5 was a big Choice he could
have just sat on the position right if
we just go back and we analyze a move
ago instead of the move H5 you mentioned
Knight to C3 that looked very good
Bishop D4 was an alternative although
that would have allowed black to Castle
because H6 wouldn't have been loose and
G4 also came to mind but probably
worried a little bit about the D5 Pawn
break I don't hate this move I don't
know
how it works because it's a very
concrete thing now black has to play
Knight takes H5 black were to play G5 it
looks like a good way to keep the king
side closed which black of course wants
but then Knight to G3 comes and you
can't cover F5 with E6 because D6 is
hanging so just tactics don't work out
for black here that forces Knight takes
five Knight takes H5 in that case
because gh5 is just too ugly to even
look at no you don't want to do that so
Knight H5 is forced and then we we
likely see G4 Knight is forced to go
back to F6 Bishop takes H6 seems very
likely and Black's King is now
permanently stuck in the center it will
never go to the king side again because
like let's say black Castle's here just
to illustrate how checkmated you are
after Bishop takes G7 you never want to
get your King on the king side with an
open H file The Rook on H1 firing down
the board and checkmating black so it
gets concrete after Bishop takes H6 why
does for the moment pin down the H file
right and it's interesting because after
Bishop H6 white gave upon to get upon is
a trade but not done directly and Knight
G8 comes to mind because of that pin you
were mentioning and that might Force
white to give up in exchange Bishop G7 I
probably play with G5 and say please
take me over here I'll get a pass Pawn
but the bishop is kind of awkward for
the time being speaking of things that
you never see before when do you see a
bishop on H6 and a Pawn on G5 that
Bishop completely cut off and sort of
attacking G7 but sort of not because
it's also pinned to work on H1 hanging
but at some point black has to do
something with that Bishop 186 it can't
just stay there forever but if he plays
Knight takes H6 whites only gets a pass
Pawn on H6 in the middle game very
unusual theme on the other hand a pass
Pawn also blockaded so it might be a
weakness in the long run it's a good
point that pawn can be awkward and
speaking of awkward we have a guest in
the studio who always makes things
awkward hey Danny how you doing buddy
hey guys I I figured if I made enough
awkward videos you guys would have no
choice but to welcome me back
I'm so excited
it's a return of last year yeah what's
going on is it is it 2022 or 2021 it's
it's whatever year you want it to be all
I know is the band's back together
aren't you guys as happy as I am let's
go where's the sofa that's what I want
to know why am I on this high chair over
here you know make me feel like a little
baby I want the sofa back I I also miss
the sofa but you know what you guys have
been crushing this commentary I'm gonna
say whether you're missing a niche or
not he's non-stop Chatterbox out there
talking about how bad this line is for
black unfortunately for anyhow also we
talked about the fact that uh he didn't
like Wesley's A3 move just so you know
he thinks that white can be even more
aggressive he seems to have a lot of
prep in this let's remember he beat me
Hal pretty handily in the game they had
right in this weird perk that now looks
like a dragadorf so shout out to Anish
bringing the commentary out in the lobby
and he thinks this is big trouble for
nihal okay not to put you on the spot or
anything but do you have any of your own
thoughts like a tribute here I also said
it was a bad draggedorf and he said you
don't have to say bad when you say
dragadorf it's just the dragon dwarf
okay but now you're getting saved from
everyone yeah so I don't I don't have
any any of my own thoughts other than I
if you want me to I will analyze but I'm
surrounded by a U.S champion and a super
GM out there so I'm just you know I'm
just here for the good the good awkward
jokes Danny what do you think about this
Rook sacrifice Wesley's up in the match
yeah and suddenly he just gives away his
Rook yeah right here he just gave up
that Rook on nature that's something
Danny would do honestly yeah are you
coaching him okay it does feel a little
unnecessary now that we talk about it um
maybe uh he remembered the uh exchange
sacrifice Hikaru made and thinks that
there's some compensation there but no
this doesn't look on this doesn't look
necessary for why why did he do that why
not just G4 even instead of H5 to begin
with we were talking about that I think
that would have been a good choice it
would have been a pragmatic one but he's
going for the kill it feels like because
when we take stock of the position black
does have two Rooks so one Rook here
against this Knight but your king is
stuck in the center and Bobby you were
highlighting this before right that King
is never gonna find safety H6 is a
target you'll get a minimum one pawn and
a knife for a rook do you believe in the
White's position here or do you think
that Neil should be happy about these
exchanges I believe in White's
compensation and I also believe that
nihal should be happy because his
position was objectively worse than it a
few moves before than it is now I wonder
if Wesley got some inspiration from a
recent game between Prague nantan Magnus
where early on the opening uh
pragnananta sacrificed to work on H5
totally different oh a totally different
position of course but same theme same
opening in fact the Pierce slash modern
I wonder if he got some inspiration from
that because Magnus was on the back for
the whole game a brilliant game almost
didn't survive so maybe he's thinking I
can do that too but from a practical
perspective I mean I I would love to
even back up it just doesn't make sense
to me that we're in this position when
Wesley was
totally in control didn't have to
sacrifice The Exchange to play G4 here
could play Knight D4 could play Knight
C3 right every one of those moves seems
to maintain the edge
so I'm with you father you you know uh
top level chess better than me of course
and uh if he's taking inspiration for
progdan on this game with Magnus maybe
but look at the time it's a little bit
telling to me that if Wesley was super
confident he might also have a little
more on the clock and if I'm nihow like
you said Bobby even if I'm worse I'm
like well at least I have a chance now
but Danny do you think that just the
fact that he sacrificed Rook that's
already a sign of confidence that he's
not shying away from a fight even though
he's up in the match he still wants to
try to extend the lead Danny I'm going
to take this one for you because we saw
Wesley give away that Rook on d8
yesterday against the car and that was a
bad decision yeah so I'm not saying that
this was a terrible one white still has
clear compensation but Danny what do you
make of that because two days in a row
yeah and I'm okay the email bar sliding
up a little bit right as I'm about to
say I'm liking the house uh position I
guess what I will say is I'm liking how
quickly nihal has played he's played
Rook G8 Bishop AJ Queen C7 and Rook d8
all within less than a minute pretty
sure he was under 12 minutes when that
started so at the very least nihal is
showing that he has a plan he wants to
try to play D5 he's going to try to open
the position let me just ask you Bobby
okay so if you like what Wesley's doing
how is white justifying The Exchange
sack long term with with D5 coming well
I think a few things first of all the
pawn H6 it's not really a pawn it's like
a zombie on the board upon is at some
point dropping off so white does
actually have a knight and a pawn for
The Rook which is almost an even
material battle balance you know we can
say three and one against five it's it's
still a sacrifice but it's very close
material and the other thing is Black's
King's still stuck in the center and has
no way to escape except maybe doing some
sort of weird gymnastics involving King
D7 C8 but concrete this is very concrete
and concretely white has a move here
Queen to F2 which carries a big threat
Bishop to B6 would be winning the rook
and the game if black were to allow it
so this is a position where white will
try to create one move threats try to
stretch black thin I I even remember a
quote I think it was about Judy Polgar
where her style was described as she
attacks you here then she attacks you
there and you think yeah you cover this
threat then you cover that threat but
then at some point you just can't cover
them all because they're coming at you
from all sides so why does trying to
stretch black thin here by attacking him
from first this side and then that side
and using the weak King on E8 I like it
and I just want to say that your
instructive point about the fact that
Black's King isn't going anywhere oh
what I don't know why the computer
doesn't like that we might want to dive
into it but I I think that's an
important long-term point right for
viewers watch teaching that sometimes
the compensation doesn't immediately
reveal itself but every time the
position opens up a little more every
time white makes a new threat your
chances of blundering in Practical
chests rapid chess As Time ticks away
are always higher when you have a king
in the center I'll just push back a bit
on that because I think black is the one
who wants to open up the position yeah
and specifically here I think that's the
reason why Bishop D4 was a extremely big
mistake because now black plays E5
Bishop moves back and D5 and the thing
is the reason that black wants to open
up the position is because Rooks love
open files and black has an extra Rook
so he needs to use that Advantage minor
pieces they love to maneuver and try to
find Outpost especially at night on H5
you know white would love to play Slow
maneuvering game trying to find better
places for his minor pieces but black is
just opening everything up trying to
trade another pair of Rooks and with
each trade Black's material advantage
Advantage will be more and more felt
yeah this is a shocking move I think
Bishop D4 just walks right into the pawn
break in the center instead of moving
Knight F4 would have stopped D5 it's
clear with the move Rook to d8 that is
what nihal's plan is so I'm very
surprised to see Wesley allow it to
happen maybe he thinks that the king's
stuck in the center will give him
compensation and even more than that and
the move E5 in general like from a
principal point of view that hands white
the F5 Square this Knight can Venture
back but there's just no time for it as
we're talking about D5 is blasting the
center open that may seem bad when you
have a king there but with a bishop and
a rook seeing the light of day Black's
extra material is going to make its
presence felt and you see Nihao leaning
in he had that edge on the clock and now
he's going to use it he's uh almost been
thinking for about two minutes and I
think that's because he I said this
before right before they agreed to a
draw in the in the other match with Gary
uh that he maybe smells blood in the
water he gets that uh little razor
focused look sorry again for the awkward
reference to our sponsor not sorry sorry
not sorry chat razor Focus from nihal
sarin as he gets ready to maybe play E5
I think this is just a case of a pure
blunder from Wesley's point of view I
think he just missed D5 yeah he was
maybe thinking black will play Bishop D4
D5 and calculated something there and
just completely missed the move E5 as
possible because from a positional point
of view it's of course it's obviously
good move once you see it but it's a
little bit unusual to block the bishop
off on h8 but of course it carries a
very concrete idea E5 followed by D5 so
yeah nihal sees it now he's just
calculating the consequences okay I'm
gonna push back because I know I was
also saying this is shocking from Wesley
so I'm gonna push back against myself
okay sorry don't push too hard but if E5
this bishop can slide back somewhere
else on the diagonal and then H6 is
hanging from the queen so by pushing the
pawn up to E5 I feel like there's some
loose squares in Black's position that
give white some counter chances maybe
it's after E5 this bishop goes from F2
to H4 go out for the F6 Square something
like that black should be better I'm not
going to deny that but there is clear
compensation or at least clear threats
that Wesley can make use of so let's
speak concretely because actually what
you said is is very relevant I think
let's say the bishop were to go back to
F2 D5 Queen takes H6
D takes C4 again chess is always a
concrete game if the king were on A2 I
think white would have a brilliant move
here Bishop to B6
and then all the taxes would work but if
you play Bishop B6 here Rook takes D1
that comes with a check and it's these
little details the King on B1 rather
than A2 where you know if it weren't
check why would capture the queen on C7
and restore the material balance or in
this case material disbalance but
instead of just like losing all his
pieces and the other line you said
Bishop F2 D5 followed by Bishop H4 maybe
that's the best way for white to go but
after Rook to D7 I don't see how you
make use of that F6 Square because if
Knight F6 black captures and the more
important thing is D takes E4 is coming
not only with the gain of material but
also with the discovered attack on the
queen on D2 well we're gonna see this
because Bishop F2 and D5 so nihal plays
what we were expecting and it's a big
moment here for Wesley so Demi he has
the lead we know how confident Wesley
can become and when he's confident good
luck to anybody beating him but all of a
sudden he might be a bit rattled by his
own mistake by playing Bishop D4 I agree
with you and I was watching Wesley so's
body language really closely because you
guys had the chest handled so that I did
my job I was watching his body language
really closely and I saw a little bit of
of a shake hand and Wesley not in a
motive player right obviously unlike
players we know like akara Nakamura for
example but I saw a little bit of a a
little bit of a head shake there and I
think Wesley uh revealed revealed that
he might have been a little frustrated
with what he missed I still like this
line let's go back to a bishop H4 that
you were talking about Fabi Rook to D7
and let's say there's Queen takes H6 now
asking for a friend because we all see
the best move here I see it too but
Bobby I'm gonna let you say what the
best move is for black because everyone
wants to know I I just don't see what
the problem is after d takes E4 it looks
very scary because all White's pieces
are fiery now on H5 Bishop H4 Black's
King is actually in a stalemate at the
moment but you can't use F6 Square
that's the most important thing and the
other important thing is that a trade of
Rooks will not only limit White's
attacking potential but actually lead to
a counter-attack let's say Rotex D7
Queen takes D7 and let's make one more
move Bishop to F6 you're thinking oh I'm
trading off Bishops and the Knight is
coming to F6 and everything's working
out and then suddenly Queen D1 comes I
got this bishop D5 okay I just wanted
yeah we all saw it and and that's it
that's good yeah you would have beaten
Wesley too it's like we're all
calculating at such high levels I'm just
hoping that Chad's following us that's
all well you know Bishop H4 has been
played so Rook D7 we're been calculating
that we don't play Rook D6 because the
Rook becomes a little loose Square there
are two white pieces staring down D file
so Rook D7 allows the threat of D takes
E4 to happen next so Rook D7 Queen takes
a chick maybe the key for Wesley is
keeping more pieces on the board so just
to show you a sample line I feel like
this in five minutes you can correct me
if you find something for black but Rook
E1 Sliding Away from the trade and if
you take on F3 say You're really greedy
now a knight to F6 carries more threat
to it or Bishop F6 your idea because
there's Rook takes E5 and you mentioned
the King has no safe squares Rook takes
E5 is already a checkmating threat yeah
I think I think the important thing is
and what you said is is absolutely
correct that once you're in a bad
position it doesn't mean that the game
is over you just need to find a way to
keep the complexity in the position
which also helps if you keep more pieces
on the board like rookie1 does and the
other thing is since it's a rapid time
format and these players will at some
point get into time trouble make sure
that your opponent has an abundance of
choice as long as it's not all winning
choice but if it's a difficult choice
and after rookie one it is actually kind
of a difficult choice because Black's
move isn't immediately evident you know
black has a lot of choices Queen D6 Rook
D6 e takes F3 as you mentioned of course
always an option Queen C6 all sorts of
options so you keep that complexity into
position make your opponent think about
it rookie one is is a great practical
chance but still the more we look at how
this position has gotten I mean it's a
three result position it's spice spice
all over the place and Nihao has an edge
on the clock the more I'm I'm just
looking back and and kind of questioning
the decision to sacrifice The Exchange I
know we could say sacrificing the
exchange was not the blunder this bishop
deformers calculation was but I just
feel like we're the lead in the match
with a position that is you know you can
grind that position in a number of ways
that don't allow your opponent to
counter Chances The Exchange sack does
I'm I'm a little surprised Wesley it
seems it seems not like his character
right not the way he does these I mean
Robert I'll ask you what do you think
about that I just feel like I was
surprised to see Rook takes H5 from from
Wesley yeah we keep using these insights
and we see the Wild Games yeah sarin he
a good percentage of his games go down
that direction Wesley so is not like
that he likes to have the solid
positional style where he can play for
small venges here and there but he
doesn't want pieces flying we saw what
happened yesterday in sakaru yeah pieces
were just going all over the place and
he almost lost the threat of the game
credit to him for moving on and even
winning that game but right now you can
see Wesley he's deep in the think tank
down to three minutes to nearly seven
for nihal Queen takes H6 is one option
Rook I mean there's no rookie one you're
just on the same line I guess that could
transpose into the same variation but I
just don't see that many moves for him
and he seems like a player who is not
comfortable right now
well he might not be comfortable right
now but there's about 55 000 total
people that are comfortable shout out to
33 000 of you on Twitch hit the follow
button if this is your first time that's
where the biggest events in chess
happened and shout out to everybody over
there on YouTube this has been this is
epic this is hype welcome to the cgc
finals uh sorry guys just doing my I
blacked out for a second what were you
talking about well you know the thing is
I think Wesley is sort of it's strange
to say this when he's in a losing
position but I think he's sort of
feeling himself in this tournament he
feels very good and sometimes that leads
to some overconfidence you know you
think oh I'm on fire I can do anything
and Wesley is a player who when he's
confident he plays really really good
actually we are seeing the line that we
discussed but wait what's happening for
oh you know what queen D1 King A2 Bishop
D5 looks like Checkmate but the C4 comes
oh my gosh and actually black resigns
there well maybe wait it's not resigns
there's King D7 but still this is not
what black wants to go for no because
you're blundering into a Checkmate you
think you're gonna Checkmate your
opponent and then you walk into one
Danny uh you might know a thing or two
with that
that was my luck so bad that was the one
line that I was flexing that I
calculated as well as Bobby and it turns
out it's the one way black can lose this
position Man story in my life all right
but okay but seriously this is
fascinating Wesley is somehow alive
allowing this incredible Queen D Queen
D1 and Bishop D5 but black is still in
good shape here I guess even
a simpler move to defend and you even
have a Perpetual I guess maybe if you
want it yeah black can definitely
probably make a draw in some of these
positions but clearly nehal wants more
and Danny well we love having you on set
here we're going to send you back over
there and we'll see you right after this
game is done between nihal and Wesley so
appreciate you guys are we so we can
hang out later or what are you doing
we're going to do something yeah okay uh
we'll just wipe them off we'll just text
you Danny get out of here bye Danny well
we are back here in the thick of things
in this game between Wesley so and nihal
sarin Niels aren't down one and a half
but with the black pieces Fabi it's been
looking good for him he is spending his
time wisely but how tricky is this
position because the eval Bar says huge
advance for black I feel like you could
walk into tons of different Perpetual
checks and you could even lose the game
as we showed in the other variation this
is super tricky I I mean when I see it
and you know the computer might say
something the bar might be all the way
in Black's Direction this is really
tricky key this is purely concrete Queen
D1 is not working out for black which is
the main issue for him and white
starting Queen xz5 and there's actually
no way to defend the threat of Queen
takes C5 so you just have to allow it so
I think e takes F3 is a very logical
Choice Queen takes E5 is forced the good
news from nihal's point of view is that
white Smooths are forced so he can
calculate relatively easily in that way
but you know you play King to f8 here
and then there's all sorts of checks
there's like Queen to C5 check and where
you go I don't think you if you go to G7
I don't think that you are winning I
don't know if you get mated you're
probably still fine or you just have to
you know go back to f8 but uh here
you're not winning the game anymore so
does that mean after a queen to E5 Queen
E6 is a forced move but then Queen B8
checked and then Bishop C8 is force in
that case to avoid a Perpetual maybe it
works out and nihal is a great
calculator so he'll probably figure this
out but Wesley is keeping it tricky yeah
this bishop can just start trying to
distract this queen things like that but
you all right the great calculator is
Neil sarn and we see e takes F3 is
played that is the best move and for
Wesley the key is making sure that he
has tricks available to him this Rook
cannot leave the back rank it whoever
goes to G6 Queen h8 is check and mate
because the bishop slices off the
diagonal the king cannot Escape so The
Rook is stuck there's no Rook takes G no
one this queen can't move Queen E7 mate
I was thinking that Danny would suggest
Rook G6 as a way to defend defend
Black's King and I was getting ready to
to say no no no Queen h8 there with
Checkmate so yeah black can definitely
lose this position if he's very careless
well let me ask you what's Black's next
move maybe it's just E4 E3 E2 something
like that but black doesn't really have
moves so I'm trying to figure out a way
for white to play a bishop D3 I can't
get away with that because Queen takes
you through his check but you know what
I mean he plays King C1 for that very
exactly exactly your ID he plays King to
C1 the question is
yeah you you might not be winning
immediately on the spot with black but
if white has no threats either if Queen
E5 is not working can black just play E4
here like the material advantage at this
point is too massive to ignore it's not
only an exchange it's those connected
past pawns on e4 and F3 that end game
will just mean you know game over if we
ever get there uh of course Wesley will
do everything in his power to avoid
getting there but after E4 I don't see
what you're doing the other problem is I
would love to set a bishop to H3 and G5
for white to get that Bishop into the
game but then it blocks off that Queen
Bishop battery that potentially
checkmates on E7 or d8 so you have no
way of getting the F1 Bishop into the
game after E4 I just don't see White's
next move yeah what we're trying to
highlight is if this bishop can chase
this queen somehow actually I'll show a
very direct sequence if you play E4 and
I play A4 and I take here and you don't
play E2 and go and win or queen D2 check
and mate me if you take back here my
threat is Bishop takes distracting this
queen because when the queen leaves
there's Checkmate in one on two
different squares E7 or D and that was
fabi's point about trying to get the
bishop to 8 H3 and play G5 but if you
play G5 the bishop on H4 is cut off so
Bobby I do think his idea might be for
once they play A4 something like that
and if this Pawn keeps going maybe you
can bring your Bishop to D3 I just don't
think that you're quite in time but you
are blocking Black's immediate checks
and threats so it gets confusing for
nihal yeah I think the line you
mentioned with A4 already played and E4
and E3
if that works out it's just Child's Play
for a calculator of knee house status uh
E4 it looks very logical but after B
wait you want quincy queen C7 was played
he went 27 to protect and immediately
Wesley went A4 oh that was a mistake I
see what I see what went wrong I was
thinking the queen like how did the
queen get there because Queen was so
good on the on DC it wasn't me I promise
but he wanted to stop critics E5 so
that's why he played it maybe he missed
the move A4 right because the point
everybody is a b takes A4 the bishop
goes to C4 now we just showed you why
the queen can't take Queen E7 is check
and mate and there's a huge threat let's
say you make a random move like A5 well
Bishop B5 check his lights out but
Bishop takes F7 does the trick the queen
takes the bishop we're just talking
about the importance of the Queen's
placement Queen d8 is check and made so
all sorts of sacrifices here and I'm
worried for nehal look at these last
moves he went Bishop C6 to defend the
pawn and then Bishop G3 quickly played
by Wesley going after E5 this bishop is
a bit loose on C6 B5 under attack the
trajectory of this game is going
Wesley's favor you know what changed
probably Niha was thinking that Bishop
H4 can never go away because it has to
create the made into threats with Queen
seven or queen d8 but
the bishop on G3 it would allow Queen E7
if the bishop were still in B7 and black
would love to trade Queens but here
Queen E7 drops the bishop on C6 which
was just put there by nihal so that's
why the position changed and uh Wesley
changed his strategy the first strategy
was to attack B5 trying to get the
bishop F1 in the game now the strategy
is take E5 and Chase blacks Queen around
again you know Queen went to C7 after
Bishop 5 they'll have to go to D7 not
exactly what he's what he wants or what
he's going for so yeah this is this is
getting sharp this is no longer so easy
and Wesley just shook off that hand he's
like oh I'm on fire right now going
after the E5 Pawn but even single moves
here are different he played Rook G6
allowing Queen h8 Wesley plays that
quickly and if King goes to E7 I'm
already looking at Bishop takes E5
you're getting after that King this
bishop can come to D3 at some point to
attack The Rook I feel like Neil really
might be more likely to lose this game
than to Win It
I don't know if I'd go so far yet but
yeah getting low on time with your king
in the center black can't check the
white king so white king is for the
moment safe this is scary stuff in fact
yeah what do you do here because if you
take on G4 it's already Bishop takes E5
with Queen F6 or Bishop F6 is a threat I
actually don't know what you do to me
like the first movie that comes to mind
is Rook to E6 because it defends E5 but
then Bishop H4 is coming oh my gosh five
Queen f8 I mean your king is getting
surrounded by the Bishops which that
mish1 F1 we said if it's on the game
white has no chance but it's getting
into the game now he should have played
E4 that was clear but now he's in big
trouble he's 40 seconds left does Neil
sarn he cannot afford to lose this game
and Fabi you said rookie 6 looks the
most natural I think another movie F2
just throw away the pawn distract
White's pieces the bishop needed to stay
on this diagonal to cover F1 so it can't
take on G6 but neon not down to 25
seconds he's amazing bullet player but
with one minute 18 seconds it feels like
Wesley so is now in control yeah the
problem with F2 is that not only do you
have to calculate Bishop H4 check and
your King is potentially getting under
attack and he does play it so he might
have calculated that but also after
Bishop takes F2 you have to play E4 and
then Bishop C5 check so many checks from
both sides of the boards that you have
to calculate and 19 seconds not easy but
if anyone could do it it is nihal who
can try to you know
get through the Labyrinth of variations
in this position you can't play F6 as
Queen H7 is checked to the king and the
Rook over here the bishop still covers
and when he gets King D6 out in the open
after Queen to f8 which looks like the
most natural move he does he want to go
to D5 is that really it King of the Hill
style I think the King goes there and
there's not a single good check for
white yeah any check will lose material
but still if if you ever get to that
King and Wesley didn't go for it he took
the pawn also makes a lot of sense
because the problem for black is E4 no
longer works Bishop to G3 check would
win the queen that's right Queen Fay
check now available the queen can block
to E7 so you can get away with that The
Rook it protects that Queen which is
very important but this queen can go
from f8 to B8 and so on maybe there's at
least a draw by repetition for Wesley in
this position I think that Wesley can
get a draw if he wants at this point
nihal will will be happy with the draw
but does Wesley want more I mean look at
any house time like if I were in
Wesley's position I would already think
I need to win this game I might even
think my position is objectively winning
because you never know bikes King could
get checkmated we see that the position
is level it's a draw but I would try to
either flag knee-hull or Checkmate him
one second oh my gosh he got the move
with one second minute Queen page at
Queen C7 so Wesley can make a draw here
if he wants it he has Bishop C5 check
Bishop H4 what was rookie seven isn't
Bishop H4 just winning material on the
spot what was that move oh my God I
think Neo's playing for a win but he's
really playing for a loss here and
Wesley down to 15 seconds himself he was
Bishop F5 he cuts this king off B4 and
Bishop C5 would be Checkmate but now B4
opposant don't forget about that rule so
it's Queen H6 oh my gosh we need two
queen D2 is Checkmate okay C4 you're not
escaping no you're not Queen D3 He just
got himself checkmated
it's me oh my God and C4 C4 came before
Queen c3's Checkmate King A2 Queen a3's
Checkmate it's game over it's just
Checkmate and Wesley so finds it and he
goes up two points and is finally
collaps his hand you see the smile on
his face Wesley so in staring down
defeat he escapes not just with a half
point with a full point and he now is in
charge here in the championship match
Fabiano that was a shocking a shocking
gets to me that is the worst thing that
could have happened for nehal Not only
was he in a great position to win and
come back but this is just a disaster
minus two Wesley is a huge huge favorite
at this point and not only that but the
momentum the positive emotions I don't
understand Rook t7 like maybe things go
wrong and you just try to make a drama
rookie seven trying to win that position
you can't do that with no time on your
clock and maybe that's what happens when
you trust your bullet skills because you
are a bullet beast but it was not meant
to be in this game Wesley so takes game
three Fabiano I'm still surprised and
this is going to be a big question for
you I'm sorry to put you on the spot but
is this match over
it might be getting to that point if I
were nihal already very desperate
situation something has to happen I
think he needs to win the next game
that's some that's the main thing if
there's a draw if Wesley holds that last
game and go into some more it's a
two-point lead I would put Wesley at
like 98 chance to win this match and the
momentum is definitely not a knee house
favor as well no it's not and if he's
gonna win some games he needs to play
better and we're gonna dial in to this
moment in the game that we just saw
between Wesley and nihil and Fabiano at
this point Wesley had the better
position with the white pieces he made
the decision to play H5 and it's one
that we really didn't like we didn't
like it and it was going to turn out
very very badly for Wesley but sometimes
you take make a gutsy call and it works
out I don't know what he was thinking
with this was he thinking would Rook
takes H5 especially was he thinking I
want to win this game was he thinking I
don't care about the results of the
previous games and I I just I just want
to play chess that I like and I enjoy
and I want to sacrifice in exchange like
I said maybe he was feeling himself at
that moment but yeah it's it was a very
gutsy call and it normally should have
not turned out well because after that
mistake Bishop's D4 he was really he was
in a losing position and we could have
seen an entirely different match if this
game
I mean entirely different match
situation if this game had gone another
way a credit to Wesley so the sacrifice
we didn't love but at this point finding
Bishop F2 Bishop H4 and then playing
Queen H6 so at this point in time after
the swap on D7 we gotta take stock of
the position there's a rook on G8 white
has three minor pieces to blacks too and
after Knight F6 check Queen takes up six
this is what Wesley saw he looked this
deep into the position he realized that
black king not going anywhere that's
gonna cause niho some serious problems
yeah I think the one thing that people
sometimes underestimate about Wesley
because we think of him as this accuracy
player a player who rarely gets bad
positions and is super accurate but when
he does get in that position and I can
speak from experience in this case he
tends to to defend tremendously well
like he's a very tough nut to crack even
once he's in a losing position and we
saw that in this game we did because at
this moment here after e takes F3 credit
to the move King C1 you may be thinking
what are you doing with your king the
whole point everybody is that Bishop D3
a move ago would not have worked because
Queen takes D3 is check and that means
that white King has to move the queen
goes back for black but if you were
given a free turn after King to C1 now
Bishop D3 the queen cannot capture
because this queen will land on E7 with
Checkmate so instead of the McQueen
seven game I think Fabiano this was
where things turned away from nehal and
into Wesley's favor because Neil did not
make this move E4 I think E4 we might
have seen nihal win Queen C7 was one of
those I hesitate to call this but it
sort of is it's a lazy move you just
want to defend your your stuff your
opponent E5 you don't want to calculate
Queen E5 at any moment and I think he
missed A4 he didn't realize that that
side of the board is also a way for
white to get the bishop in and it's a
bit surprising because you think okay A4
I take the pawn thanks for the Free Pawn
but then this bishop C4 move comes in
you can't take it because of the quick
the checkmates on E7 d8 and you have to
suddenly deal with this threat of Bishop
takes 07 low on time super unpleasant
and yeah I think Queen C7 is actually
was the first Turning Point even though
it wasn't the objectively bad move it
was the first turning point in terms of
making the position more difficult for
me how to handle and speaking of turning
points Bishop C6 then we saw the move
Bishop G3 turning from one diagonal to
the next threatening this Pawn E5 and I
think this is amazing recognition from
Wesley I know when I was looking at this
position I'm never moving that Bishop
because if the queen on C7 moves there's
Checkmate that's a great diagonal to be
on but he recognized that black can't
really move his pieces that well the
biggest idea is we were indicating
earlier E4 and push this Pawn up the
board so Bishop G3 Rook G6 played and
Fabi at this point it felt like Wesley
was getting the upper hand but things
just got out of control after F2
reasonable move the king escapes and
here not taking the draw Fabi that was
just absolutely baffling you know what's
interesting to me I I really wanted to
see if Wesley was going to take the draw
because after Queen E7 he still had
another option which was to play Queen
V8 Queen z7 and suddenly Bishop C5 check
you can't take it so you're forced to
play King D7 because otherwise you lose
your queen and then white has to move
like Queen to f8 and with four seconds
on your clock good luck finding the best
move here for black so I really wanted
to see if Wesley was going to take a
draw or go for more but instead nihal
made an inexplicable decision Rook to E7
is it because he was afraid of Bishop C5
or is it because he wants to win but
that's just too strange for me to
understand because even after Bishop
page four what winning chances do you
have you're no longer going to be out
material because you're losing your
exchange back and your King's still
stuck in the center so as a winning
attempt this one just doesn't make any
sense maybe he was just you know those
last few seconds of panic and as a
player who tends to panic when I'm in my
last few seconds I can't fault nihal for
for this mistake but still it was a very
costly one for him but I do appreciate
your elaboration on that line because in
particular here Bishop C5 check King D7
Queen f8 I think that's a very scary
line to face and so Neil likely saw that
and went with Rook E7 but the way this
game concluded Bishop F5 your king is
about to be checkmated just two moves
away B4 Bishop C5 would be mate your
king is nowhere to go and after Queen H6
check the only move here is rookie six a
very difficult move to play in time
travel because you're simply giving away
material and your King still isn't that
safe the evaluation bar may say why it's
only slightly better but practically
speaking with just mere seconds on your
clock in all likelihood you're going to
be in trouble so the reason in fact that
black is in trouble there is not because
of his King safety because suddenly his
King is safe there because there's not
much material left but that g Pawn is
actually running out the board Queen's
f8 comes in and G5 you know G6 black
would have to find a way to stop the
pawn so even here I think practically
speaking this is almost 1-0 with you
know three seconds on your clock against
18 seconds so I don't know if this would
have helped nihal save the game but at
least he wouldn't have gotten checkmated
immediately while Checkmate did happen
Queen D2 all of this was forced at this
point Neil's King could not escape and
queen C3 is Checkmate on the board and
that wraps up game three analysis so
Bobby and I we covered it all we had to
shake our heads a little bit but when
all said and done Wesley so large and in
charge we'll send to you Danny and the
Fellas
wow well as we peaked at nearly 60 000
viewers we're all hoping that the chess
in this match has not peaked yet but
we're going to dive into that right now
first remind you Amon Hamilton Danny
wrench James Canty and now Daniel
noraditski sits in for Fabiano caruano
was let's take a look at the scores and
show everybody where we're at as we said
we're hoping the match hasn't peaked but
Wesley so he we saw him clap his hands
and then guys as we came in he was
rushing out he was giving himself a
round of applause you see that he was
clapping his own chest as he takes a
two-game lead over Nihao Sauron in what
was incredible fashion so quickly let's
dive in and talk about it uh it's
interesting to say Amman that that
moment those moves
we're worth a hundred thousand dollars
potentially to Wesley so if he goes on
to win the first Global Championship
exactly and you know what Danny we often
talk about Nihao and how good he is when
he's low on time I feel like Wesley
doesn't get enough credit yeah you know
there's another element being low on
time as well you can put pressure on
your opponent in the most devilish ways
and Wesley is so good at that he knows
what you want to do he knows how to play
against it and Wesley just kept that
time scramble going and it just felt
like it was going to Trend more and more
in his Direction he probably thought at
the beginning oh I'm happy with a draw
but near the end he was probably playing
that for a win despite the evaluation it
really feels like a bad sign can't you
because those were I think the type of
scrambles the mutual time pressure the
crazy tactics everywhere that you're
like all right if any hell is going to
strike those are the kind of games he's
going to do it in but not so nothing's
working nothing's working at all we need
to figure something out right now
fletchley so is on the cusp of winning
the whole thing right yeah we did the
modern defense didn't work right we've
seen him cross the modern with Hikaru
right like why would we go back to the
modern defense here so again another
decision on the opening prep with that
repertoire we got to have it we got to
have it down and I mean two games out
already two down it's rough it's very
bad for them we gotta we gotta make some
changes yeah yeah I agree things are bad
on all fronts but especially you know
knee-haul the white pieces showed a lot
of indecision in the last game of the
Catalan Wesley has had ample time to
prepare for his London so that couples
with the fact that Wesley just won a
Time scramble that was right up
knee-hal's alley yeah does not bode well
for any Hall's chances in the rest of
the match he needs a complete 180. now
to Neil's credit he's done well with
white so I want everyone to stay seated
don't go anywhere because I think if
we're going to see The Comeback start it
starts in the next game he gets the
first move it's where his repertoire is
at its best your thoughts on what he
might be able to come up with now that
he's back with white well Danny I think
with the white pieces we saw a fairly
unremarkable attempt in this match
earlier on so he needs something and I
think Fabi kind of said it best you know
kanty was alluding to it he needs to
play what he knows but also stay away
from those like high level openings full
of preparation where Wesley is going to
be your number one enemy right take it
take it into Waters that you're familiar
with and I think Nihao uh needs a win
with the one piece is it must win time
is it when you go home then it's weird
he might even go London system I can't
believe you're even saying that like oh
yeah we must win London who says that
right like but I don't argue anymore
right but the London I mean he's been
doing well with it obviously he knows it
very well so I guess he's got to go back
to his roots there I mean having played
New Hall a ton online he is a good E4
player like he has his lady four at all
this tournament but he is capable of
pushing the King's Pawn forward okay
he's got preparation there also one B3
often an overlooked way interesting to
it's B3 itself has become pretty
theoretical in recent years but it's
still not comparable to the Berlin yeah
so for Neil it's important to do that
without tilting and playing like 1a4 so
you need you need a cross between
something you're comfortable with he
didn't do them do do that in the first
game of the black but at the same time
you have to get Wesley out of theory
kind of like what nehal did in this last
game let's not lose sight of the fact
that his opening did end up turning into
the potential position yeah we were
surprised at one point by The Exchange
Sacramento yes I was when I was in the
booth with the guys for a moment turns
out Wesley knew all along that it was
the right way to put pressure on the kid
whose presence is not here in Toronto
but another person's presence who is now
missed at this point is Hikaru Nakamura
he lost to Wesley so yesterday in the
semi-finals but earlier this week when
in a much better mood Hikaru hung out
with James
foreign
we are here with the man the myth the
legend himself and nobody else The champ
is here hey Cara Nakamura man what's up
well it's good to be here got to ask you
now that you uh missed the world
champion do I have to refer to you as
more as Road Champion car Nakamura every
time we talk to you nah all right okay
before I'm a streamer first if I had to
I was going to have to do it yeah
how are you world champion uh Nakamura
you need some water you know what I mean
what scares you the most
um you mean in general yeah like
anything anything I mean the only thing
that I really don't like her yeah like
spiders and like um cockroaches probably
really cockroach so if you saw a
cockroach would you scream would you
like yeah
um it depends if I'm wearing shoes I'd
probably just try to kill it yeah if I'm
not wearing shoes yeah I would I would
probably try to run away pretty quickly
perfect perfect good to know so how do
you handle the high stakes pressure of
course look you already just won some
money you've done it before so now we
got 200 000 on the line of course one of
the biggest paydays of the year
um how do you handle the high-speed card
I mean it's just a chess tournament
all right oh you hear that Chad it's
just a chess tournament right 200 000 on
the line it's just a tournament right
congrats on everything thank you and
good luck to you in the cgc thanks
[Music]
I think it's more than just a chess
tournament and of course we miss Hikaru
but look he's had a great month he won
the Fisher random World Chess
Championship he is now a feed a world
champion he had a great run at the cgc
to get third uh we're surprised maybe to
not see him now in the final but talk a
little bit about hikaru's cgc overall
Donya as a guy who covered as much of it
as almost anybody yeah I think it was a
very solid performance obviously he car
was going to be disappointed in anything
except first place but chess fans tend
to fall prey often to the recency effect
where they see that he car when the fish
are random like he beat Magnus therefore
he must beat Wesley that's not how high
level logic works I mean yeah I think
hikaru's third place has more to do with
Wesley than it does with the car's
performance the car did everything
within his power You could argue that
his opening choices could have been
different you know with 2020 hindsight
but at the end of the day like Wesley is
displaying some of the best rapid form
we have ever seen and you know that's
something that Hikaru can use as
consolation he didn't beat himself yeah
he he ran up against Wesley he didn't
beat himself still playing incredible
chess we've been incredibly impressed by
Hikaru James your thoughts on I know I
know you had your guy hikar here you
broke your bracket that's really what he
said he broke man yeah broke my bracket
man but of course at the same time look
sometimes the bully Gotta Give hit
sometimes you know he he wins everything
all the time right so when he doesn't
wins like he didn't win what do you mean
right it's like crazy the World Turns
and Spins this stuff but at the same
time I mean Carl did a great run he made
it to the semifinals only losing to the
guy that's beating nehal like yeah
ridiculous Wesley's in excellent form
right now the only person that could
take out Hikaru is inform Wesley like
that yeah I think Danny the the thing
about uh hikaranakamura is we hold him
to these incredible standards yeah and
we have to remember that you know shared
third place in the cgc is an insane
result yeah let's just talk about how
good of an accomplishment that is but
for Hikaru of course anything but first
we do hold him to Great standards and
you know there was a very dramatic
moment everyone caught at the end but
between Hikaru and Wesley when when he
knew it was over
got up and uh you know I don't know what
he turned around and said I am a pretty
decent lip reader I saw it live but I
couldn't I couldn't make it out but you
know I think uh I think Hikaru he he
wanted this right but we know he'll be
back like you said him on I mean he ran
up against the guy that you picked in
your bracket in the end Hikaru was
trying to help your bracket I I think
that's probably one of the last things
go ahead and say that but uh you know
obviously Hikaru tremendous player and
yeah he could have gone all the way that
was a coin flip match
we've still got more to do here there's
still lots of chests ahead and chess.com
brought a small army to Toronto
including eight commentators the other
night most of us got together for a
night of duck chess push-ups and plenty
of laughs
[Music]
to be like serious so people can talk
and chill and like yeah
exactly exactly exactly yet okay
[Music]
oh man I gotta take off my shirt
how much he's taking 30 seconds
all right let's go yeah oh my God
[Music]
this is so fun I love it
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie the first time I put
the duck down hard enough to hear it
squeak I about lost it it was the most
it was the most fun thing I had that
night we did way too many push-ups but
the clap push-ups bro that was nutty hey
look you know there's nothing to a Jedi
of course I'm in uh in there me and
flexi so hit the gym every morning you
know so we doing our thing man it was
fun Donya do you want to tell the world
what your score wasn't Bullet versus
Fabi or you want me to do it I want you
to do it it was close it was cool okay
Donya is not one to brag I will just
wear the face of Shame when they sat
down I was like Bobby's gotta be the
favorite right an OTB bullet right
that's the only reason I actually
managed Donya might be the best
over-the-board bullet player I've ever
seen he beat Fabiano in total 11 to five
it was seven to three at one point just
absolutely blew our minds the only other
thing that blew our minds about the
night was that Amman wasn't there we
don't know where you were you want to
tell me what you were doing well first
of all Danny I was boxing okay I was I
was training for a very important chess
boxing match but I mean do I know how to
clear out a room or what I showed up
it's just it wasn't in the tape what was
yeah this representation I showed up
just everyone left immediately you're
right bro in fact you know what bro hold
up let's get it come on you got chess
boxing coming up
right now right now okay oh my Lord
how you doing Chad look at the Forum oh
man he's clapping oh my gosh all right
well we have a quick minute everyone
my default Brave blocks ads and trackers
on every page and videos and you visit
even on YouTube no ads means even more
up to three times faster page lows
faster streaming faster playback and
faster push-ups they're still going it
means 35 percent longer battery life
while saving on mobile data and internet
bandwidth for Android iOS and desktop
get the best browser for gamer streamers
and creators switching 60 seconds be
brave do push-ups go to brave.com chess
and switch today this might be the most
important all right when we return we're
headed to our fourth and final game of
the day twitch subscribers hang tight
for more great content we'll be right
back for more from the chess.com Global
championship title match
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you ready for the trivia questions
no but let's do it anyway who is the
current prime minister of Canada the
current prime minister is of course
Justin Trudeau perfect I didn't have to
run through the multiple choice I I was
like oh it's multiple toys
yeah like I only know one Canadian
politician so if it's not Trudeau
anymore then I'm done which of these is
Toronto's hockey team or if you already
know you can just let us it's I mean of
course it's the Maple Leafs thank you
okay I think because there are two Maple
things I'm going to go with the maple
one that's how I passed my final School
exam as well Maple Leaves correct who is
Canada's top rated chess player
Alexander botas well unfortunately I
played him last week so I know the
answer it's of course I'm getting Berea
I'm not sure about Barre writing to be
honest so no one is getting younger and
oh okay I also he's not as good as he as
he used to be so
um but um I guess I didn't have some
good with Eric which of these
celebrities is not Canadian so I knew
the first two are Canadian so it must be
the Indonesian but the easiest celebrity
though
oh why well I would like choose between
dragons then you rhymes like I can't see
any of them being Canadian to be honest
and
maybe they're both Drake is actually
like the icon of Toronto this is the
trick question I'll go every living
obviously it's uh Danny Ryan but I think
his singing skills are someone behind
the other contestants
so that's okay
the speed Chess Championship is back and
bigger than ever
did he had to take the pawn on D7 the
2022 speed Chess Championship features
the most exciting lineup in SCC history
and over 100
000 in prizes representing the Next
Generation Are Notre back Abdus Torah
Arjun Eric icy nihal Serene and gukesh
domaraju defending their Elite status we
have Dimitri on draken Anish giri Maxim
vashiella grav Wesley so Lavon aronian
janapomnishi dingley Ren and Fabiano
caruana headlining this incredible field
are the reigning world chess champion
Magnus Carlson and the reigning speed
chess champion Hikaru Nakamura these 14
combatants will be joined by two
qualifiers oh my God 86. oh my goodness
he missed it the speed Chess
Championship 2022 begins November 21st
fasten your speed belts
foreign
[Music]
um
yes I was born in Vancouver crazy but as
fond as I am of that place it's pretty
tough not to fall in love with the city
of Toronto
natural beauty abounds inside Toronto
and pretty close by
the largest city in Canada the people
here have been playing chess in clubs in
universities and public parks for well
over a century
and now this wonderful place plays hosts
to the very first chess.com Global
championship finals
facing elimination for weeks two of the
world's best players are one step away
from completing their quest for the
queen-size share of the one million
dollar prize pool
one second now for Hikaru he's just
trying to prevent them for The Rook that
was the end of his chances oh my God
what a finale
[Music]
you're in the right place it's time for
the cgc's championship match Toronto
Canada officially has it all just like
my sister
Alexandra dude did you write this
she's asleep
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to Toronto and the cgc
title match inside the gameplay haul
that is the cgc champion trophy which
will be awarded on Monday also to be
awarded the 200 000 first place prize
here's what we've given out thus far on
Drake and Duda 7 rajabov took home
twenty five thousand dollars girian
Nakamura limited yesterday but for that
elimination they gained 50 Grand we'll
see if Wesley so could take home that
first place prize of two hundred
thousand dollars after tomorrow's action
but Fabiano caruana is with me here in
the studio that's the U.S chess champion
the former Challenger to Magnus Carlsen
title and Fabi Wesley so up two games
here during the break did you maybe
think it over what does nihal sarin have
to do can he do it well absolute
disaster for knee-haul that's all I all
I can think of this match so far what he
has to do in this next game is win at
any cost he can't go into that good
night silently if I if he has a coach
here that coach needs to tell him have
to win at any cost in this game if if
it's a tool point lead tomorrow almost
guaranteed victory for Wesley so this is
a must win game this is extremely high
stakes for nehal and Wesley so just such
a difficult player to defeat Hikaru
Nakamura played him in eight games a car
won zero of those eight games because
Wesley does not lose very often as you
see Wesley and nehal seated getting set
for game four the last game of today
we're gonna just dial in with Wesley so
because he had an impressive path here
Fabiano he struggled in his round of 64
matchup against Dennis lazick you also
struggled in that first matchup so no
easy opponent in this field but since
then he took down Evancho he barely got
by Jeffrey Zhang and it feels like he's
improved as the matches continued yeah I
I think that is a facet of Wesley's
personality that the better he does the
more confidence he gets and the better
it makes him play so once he started
getting into the groove of the event
getting past the early matches where
there were maybe a bit more more of
nerves like I don't want to exit early
you know and now he's he's really
feeling good about his tournament well
he's gonna be feeling good heading into
this game we'll see how the opening
stage goes Knight F3 from nihal sarin
and Fabi oh B3 so this kind of Nakamura
system adibon the Beast deserves a shout
out as well but he is trying to take
Wesley out of any sort of preparation I
was gonna say this is a Hikaru Nakamura
special if you go through his list of
recent games he cars games that is and
just make a tree you'll see legitimately
around 100 plus games with Knight of
three D5 B3 probably more than anyone so
nehal is taking a page from hikaru's
book a little bit of inspiration there
but he didn't want to do this against
Wesley which is interesting so maybe
this will work out it's sort of similar
to what he was trying against Anish
where it successfully worked out uh he
won a few games against Anisha critical
moments you know quiet position Phoenix
early B3
but this is a line that Wesley has
played before because I've seen I've
seen him have games here rapid and Blitz
Games in particular I think is the move
here Bishop yes C7 with a tactical point
that you can't take on C6 because of
that Queen to Z6 looks like you win a
pawn but in fact you would lose a piece
because it was made on H2 right I'll
show that variation real quick here that
a move ago instead of Knight to D2 if
you took on C6 that would have been a
blunder Pont take C6 Bishop takes six
well this is really the blunder because
Queen D6 attacking the bishop if the
bishop tries to take that rook in the
corner over here then Queen takes H2 is
check and make you lose a piece on the
spot so we saw instead Knight D2 Queen
D6 and G3 played that weakens the light
squares and it's just kind of a position
right where white tries to play against
this isolated Queen Pawn but when you
have an isolated Pawn the adjacent files
are open for your Rooks yeah this is a
fight between the structure and the
activity the isolated Pawn gives black a
bit of extra space because it's advanced
in the center compared to White's E3
pawn and also gives Black's pieces a bit
more freedom to develop for example the
bishop on C8 has a wide choice of
squares it can go to to G4 for example
or to H3 but once it gets there it's not
clear that it actually makes any inros
in twice position I played against niho
I think only one time at the uh fide
Grand Swiss last year and it was exactly
the same structure it was an isolated
pawn and he didn't handle it so
confidently in that game I have to say
although it did end in a draw so I'm I'm
kind of wondering if this was a good
opening choice because black gets a lot
of activity white is going out to try to
soak up the pressure it's not a very
pleasant thing to do and theoretically
speaking black is considered to have a
very good position in this line yeah the
evaluation bar is a testament to that
and I remember that game you had the
advantage he played good defense when
the time came to it but this already
seems to be a decent start for Wesley
and he's spending time so I think nihal
he's learning he needs to put pressure
on the clock in this matchup because in
game three which you just saw nehal was
very close to evening up the match score
if he found a few accurate moves we
probably could have trusted his position
a little more then his King got unsafe
and that's where things spiraled out of
control so right now it's kind of a more
solid setup but Wesley playing Bishop B6
eyeing the D4 Square I think that
previous game despite being a disaster
of course from nihal's point of view
could give him something operation that
I can now play a player of Wesley's
caliber of course he already knew that
he beat on me she beat ding but still it
gives you that feeling that okay I can
come back into this because Wesley is a
great player but he also makes some
mistakes he gets into bad positions and
I just need to take advantage capitalize
on those good positions that I do get if
I do get them on the other hand once
he's also a player who he doesn't get
many lost positions maybe he'll have
that thought that you know I got one
chance but it's not going to come so
easily the next time and look at this
tactical sequence already there's a
trade on C6 and Knight C4 comes do not
take that Knight you lose your queen so
the queen steps out the way and now we
have a bishop pair and very importantly
this bishop is finqueto on the long
diagonal the evaluation bar may say zero
slightly better for black something like
that but the long term could be
advantageous for white except for the
fact Bobby Amman when he and I were
commenting together he raises this good
point when you see a bishop pair and
then one side has a knight you ever want
to trade one of the Bishops and here
Bishop A6 before I can finish my thought
it's played because if the light score
Bishops are gone this Knight on F6
becomes a great piece hopping around
well you don't have to ask Wesley twice
this last move Bishop k6 was practically
a no-brainer from a positional uh
positional point of view because of
course black doesn't want to fight
against those two Bishops and not only
that the bishop won't see it was passive
so you want to trade it off because it
wasn't a very good piece to begin with
and after white takes if white were to
take then Rook takes black is also ready
to double on the a file putting some
pressure on A2 which suggests to me that
white will either immediately or in the
near future play A4 to me A4 is just a
very natural move you you have a
backwards pawn and you want to turn it
into potentially pass Pawn because
someday probably not anytime soon but
someday white might try B4 A5 and
convert that pawn into a pass Pawn on
the other hand black does have the
central control c6d5 very very good
Central pawns and if the pawn were to
move up to C5 it even controls more
squares the problem with that is of
course that loses doesn't lose upon but
either loses a pawn or rex black
structure because he might have to play
GTX F6 and you don't want that right
Queen takes F6 is met by Queen takes D5
that would be a free Pawn that fireman
is talking about so we see some of the
ideas here that black is going to double
in the a file and it kind of reminds me
of the game between Hikaru and Wesley
Wesley the black piece in the game he
defended quite accurately to make sure
that the game was level and then there
was a straightforward draw from there
but right now I feel like Wesley sews in
phenomenal form because he's playing
somebody who is not a renowned
theoretician where Nielsen thrives is in
these middle game positions we've looked
at the insights he plays at many Wild
games and then also the end game we saw
him beat Anish giri in a really
beautiful end game in the Armageddon
match when he was ahead on the clock
even if the theoretically should have
been dropped it was practically
difficult so I feel like it's a perfect
style to play against nihal if you're
Wesley so yeah well we see that Nihao
has a lot of wild games and the previous
game was one of them that one didn't
work out his favor but even though we
say nihal is not really a theoretical
player he was actually causing a lot of
problems with the white pieces for
anishkiri who is indeed one of the best
theoreticians in the world so he might
not be the most theoretical player but
he can still find some ideas here and
from the time expenditure so far it
seems like he knows the position a
little bit better than Wesley on the
other hand he's traded off a lot of
pieces what are your winning hopes here
against Wesley it's not very likely that
you're going to be out able to play him
from this position so the way I see it
not an opening success for nehal well
you asked that rhetorical question and I
was like I've never actually lost to
Wesley because I've never played him but
I certainly haven't beaten him you're
somebody who has played Wesley in many
games what is that kind of recipe needed
to take him down not necessarily in this
position because there aren't that many
pieces remaining but if you were in
nihal's corner what kind of suggestions
would you give I would say yeah I did
play Wesley many times over the past you
know decade or even more in fact we
played our first game in I think it was
the year 2004. I was going back a long
time
yeah it's been a while and
like how do you beat Wesley that's a
good question I have I think that the
main thing is you have to make him
uncomfortable from the start and he's
not going to be uncomfortable in this
position the way he's uncomfortable is
you play very quickly from opening you
get an opening Advantage you put
pressure on the clock you show that
you're better prepared for the position
than he is and then he starts to get a
bit shakier he starts to feel a bit less
confident and he doesn't make the sort
of move that he's
great at making you know those logical
good positional decisions uh where you
think like okay this this guy is a
positional God he's he can make All the
Right Moves he he doesn't create any
weaknesses in his position here it feels
like Wesley is is going to be very
comfortable first of all I'd like a
nickname Wesley positional God so excuse
me flexly positional God so and you've
have a lot of experience playing him and
you just kind of said it all that nobody
has the exact necessary ingredients to
beat Wesley sometimes it gets a little
bit uncomfortable but for the most part
he is a very practical player he's a
very solid player and maybe he doesn't
win games individual games as much as
some of the other top guys but he rarely
loses and Wesley he's locked in he's in
form and he's taking his time because
the position is simplified but not
simple as you're pointing out Fabiano
there are going to be some positions
where black may have to deal with an
outside pass pawn and that will not be
easy it's not like even material game is
just a draw if we can escape establish a
pass Pawn on the outside here and
White's Rooks can start barreling down
at the other pawns I feel like that
could give nehal some good chances
because outside pass pawns distract
Pieces away from the center yeah I think
that White's chances can only lie in a
potential past tape on other hand if I'm
black and I see B4 coming at me I think
okay you want to create a passport and I
probably can't stop that so I'll make
you I'll give you a pass Pawn First
after B4 I'll play C5 and you'll
probably take on C5 because you want to
create that outside pass Pawn on the
other hand the C Pawn is also past pawn
and the a pawn is kind of firmly
blockaded for the moment of course you
never know what these past pawns they
might get dangers later into the game
but black also has his fair share of
Chances with the c Pawn potentially even
D4 coming trade trade off more material
and get closer to draw of course Wesley
wants to draw on this game he re he
recognizes from the match situation that
a draw is almost akin to well at least
getting closer to a match Victory so he
wants that draw he's happy to trade off
more pieces and get into a more large
position yeah so he just slid his Rook
back to eight now it is on the clock I'm
trying to come up with ideas for white
because Black's next move it's almost
premovable C6 to C5 we just point out B4
will still be met by C5 Rook to C1 going
to the semi-open file met by C5 I think
the only move that I see that will not
be met by Siva is Queen D4 because I
don't want to uh allow this Pawn
structure to be compromised and that's
not the biggest deal in this particular
end game but Bobby Queen D4 here I feel
like that's actually an option for white
because the transition into the Rook end
game now all of a sudden if you play C5
I'm starting to wonder can I just allow
you to take me here and really try to
get this outside pass Pawn so after
Queen D4 which looks like a very logical
move
because you want to try to change the
structure a little bit make C6 more of a
backwards Pawn I actually like to move
C5 okay even though you think okay I'm
working the structure on the queen side
but thing is in Rook end games this
structure is actually not very bad for
black in Middle games you have a very
weak king and you want to avoid this at
all costs in Rook end games King safety
is not a big deal and the king is very
uh firmly situated on G7 and if we can
just go a little bit deeper let's say
white sees that black wants to play C4
plays let's say Rook F to C1
even C4 here I don't think it's terrible
let's say white takes
takes takes takes and B5 it's still
leading to very drawish types of
positions although of course you know
black would rather not do this but the
garage margin is very very high yeah if
white were to go for this this one is
actually
oh my gosh speaking of a high margin for
a drug they just agreed on a draw and
the position is equal but you were just
saying before this is great news for
Wesley so he makes the most draws by
agreement of any of the players in the
field we've seen that on his stat card
but the game's over
I I don't get it uh I'm a little bit of
shock not because the position was
better for a knee-haul of course it's
not it's an equal position
but the match situation is such that
I mean you just have to play for a win
we we said this was a must win it's not
strictly must win of course the match
continues and you know he'll have to win
two games out of four tomorrow but when
was the last time that Wesley lost two
out of four games in a match I I can't
remember it I mean I'm sure it's
happened at some point in history but
does nihal does nihal feel comfortable
in trying to play tomorrow two games
must win games just to get to an
Armageddon I can't imagine you know and
you know me I'm always clamoring to ban
the draw offer make them play it out but
somebody who did not want to play out is
Wesley so he takes that draw and now
with it a three to one lead after day
one you could not have scripted this
better for Wesley so winning with the
white pieces drawing with black
yeah I mean he's very happy about this
development you know he was probably
nervous before this game Thinking okay
Niha is going to go all out against me
try to win this game try to get back a
little bit in the match still be behind
but at least be in a better situation
and suddenly he has an effortless draw
he didn't have to do anything in this
game he didn't have to calculate
anything he he played the line he knew
traded off all the pieces draw agreed uh
ideal sewage situation for Wesley uh
maybe nihal was just I suspect this is
the case he was still a bit rattled from
that previous game and he just needed a
break he needed some sort of of you know
change in the match at least he can
rethink a strategy try to get back into
it tomorrow but it's gonna be really
tough I mean if I were in this situation
in Niha situation I would think not not
looking too good yeah I think he might
regret that game three because he did
have his chances of the Topsy Turvy one
here in game four we saw Knight F3 and
B3 the Naka system and I think nihao's
idea was just to make Wesley a little
bit uncomfortable early you said that's
one of the key things to do to beat
Wesley so but it quickly kind of
transposed into something that was
familiar a kind of English I'm going to
disagree with you a little bit there
looking at the entirety of the game and
how the opening just didn't turn out in
his favor at all I think that he just
has no openings with white wow he has
nothing to do he might have used all his
openings for Anish he might have had
something prepared for Wesley in the
catalog and thought I'll prepare a lot
for that first game and hopefully it
goes well uh that first White game and
hopefully it goes well and after that it
was just nothing like with white he has
shown no ideas and how to get an
advantage against Wesley
so I think that's that was the case in
this game this was not an opening to
like get a sharp fight this is just I
don't know what to do anymore yeah
because really just right outside of the
opening very normal moves by both we had
a position with an isolated Pawn I just
want to show you this tactic once more
this is a good way to defend C6 not with
a piece but with a tactical idea so if
the Knight captures on C6 Pawn takes
Bishop C6 hitting the Rook you win a
pawn you lose the game Queen to D6 lines
up against H2 attacks the bishop on C6
so if you cannot win this pawn and
Wesley just simply developed his pieces
in a normal way all these trades happen
and then there were simply no Advantage
for Niha whatsoever maybe he just wanted
to get this game over with
yeah sometimes the the emotions are just
too bad like you have a game like that
in the third game where you're winning
you're winning you're thinking I'm gonna
come back in the match and then suddenly
it all turns around not only do you not
win you actually lose and you just need
a break you need to stop the bleeding so
maybe that was the case in this game
yeah there was not much content in this
one only 22 moves of Chess and it was
equal the whole time so right now Wesley
so has the lead three to one and we'll
be right back in a little bit but for
now we're gonna throw it to Danny and
the Fellas there in the studio
well not much content in that game as
Robert said but we still got plenty of
content ahead in our post game show
don't go anywhere everyone we're going
to dive into the action Danny wrench
here alongside him on Hamilton James
Canty and Donya nerdinsky let's show
everyone our scores in case they're just
tuning in wondering what exactly is
going on here what's going on here is a
dominant performance by the American
Wesley so he is up three to one over
nihal sarin he won in game one and in
game three those were the decisive
victories to get him that 3-1 score
otherwise the draws also just felt
pretty easy for Wesley so
Guys Wesley so so let's dive into so's
play so uh looking at that game uh Danny
and you know the match at large yeah I
think that this game is an example of
Nihao saying look I don't want anything
worse to happen I honestly look at this
and I think he didn't want to lose
another game where the match is
basically done yeah he wasn't having a
good day he wanted to stop the bleeding
he didn't have any new ideas I didn't
mind his opening Choice actually right
but nothing was generated from it well I
was saying that that opening Choice
maybe showed us a little bit of what uh
so might have played against ikoro
Nakamura he played this Knight F3 B3
kind of inches stuff which you faced a
lot Tanya yeah but you can tell that
nihal is frustrated because Wesley plays
Bishop C7 and the first thing that goes
through mind is of course he knows this
too I mean he knows everything he sees
everything I don't know what to play uh
we'll talk about this more in a bit but
I mean nihal needs a break in the
opening he needs a little sign of
weakness from Wesley but in this last
game he seemed like a man is at a guess
and hopefully he's only out of gas for
today yeah you know Canty he played
hikaru's specialty yeah the Knight of
three B3 system we see a lot we call him
mini Hikaru often that being the hell
Soren but not able to really uh get it
get a position he could fight on for for
a win do you expect him to maybe go back
to that though in the future uh no well
nah I don't think he'll go back to that
I think in fact he needs to like you
know revamp everything so go back that's
why he got that draw you know he get hit
all right stop the bleeding good Clock
Bail light make sure that don't happen
to you yes hopefully you uh knockout
Trenton right but of course he's getting
hit there and he needs to come back you
know very strong so I think he took that
draw here today to get more time to go
into tomorrow because you got to reset I
need to look at some openings Bobby says
I had Bobby was like he has no openings
like yeah he has no opening he's like oh
my goodness Bobby said it he has no open
probably 2800 saying that right that's
tough yeah it's it's bad the situation
is bad it's hard to sugarcoat it if
you're a knee-haul you have to sugarcoat
it a two-point comeback is not
unprecedented it happening
listen nihal won two games to cut a one
point deficit against the nishkiri so
yeah we're not talking about something
totally insurmountable what's scarier is
just how solidly Wesley is playing like
it's just in against the framework of
Wesley's form Wesley's form right now is
actually scarier than the objective
necessity of making that two-point
comeback yeah even though it was only a
one point comeback against sevia and he
ultimately won that match by a game so
Nielsen is not the type of person who we
don't think is capable of a comeback
right I mean he's especially because he
he's kind of a streaky player at times
if he's rolling his style will carry him
so you think there is some chances for
him to maybe pull it together with a
good night's sleep yeah I I definitely
do Danny uh I mean do you always say
like there's a new day right I really
believe that there's you know momentum
in chess and if this match Danny took
place place over one day right now I'd
say it's Wesley's for the taking
obviously Wesley still got that edge but
going into a new day nihal needs to do
some as candy said some real revamping
work and he can definitely come back and
make this interesting tomorrow well we
will talk about that new day in a bit
but we're on this day now and it was a
good day for Wesley so Nemo is standing
by live with Wesley right now
thank you Danny I am here with Wesley
you had an absolutely fantastic day
today and you beat and Drake in in the
round of a you beat Hikaru in the
semifinals and now you are currently
having a two-point lead against nehal
what's contributing to your excellent
play uh well it's very good I mean I
think my third door mineral and the
first two went badly for finally
something's going well and I'm very
grateful for that I'm also very
fortunate actually to be here because uh
in the qualifier when I play Jeffy song
I should have actually lost that match
so like I wasn't playing well uh that
time it was like a month ago but now I'm
playing better so I'm very very glad for
that uh
um I mean obviously
at some point you get tired of losing
too many games and you want to do better
hopefully that's what's happening to me
right now of course and I wanted to ask
what happened on that game three King to
C1 yeah that's uh insane uh because
basically I'm done exchange in a pawn
before that and the nihal found all
these accurate moves E5 D5 Rook D7 like
he found all computer moves like five
moves in a row and I was reeling at that
point I was also down on time so that
was really a critical moment of the
match because he was like winning I mean
it's not an easy win but it was
definitely winning if I made one more
mistake than the game would be over
so
[Music]
yeah I was just trying to make use of
all the chances that could arise right
try to never give up and you know it
splits and anything can happen but nihal
is a great player he finds all these
resources and very little time like even
if he has a minute left he usually finds
all the best moves very quickly it's a
great
resourceful player also it's a very
strong I mean he's one of the Great
Dance of Indian chess and just getting
close to 2700 So
yeah I was very fortunate to find his
Kingfield one turned out to be the best
move uh I was regretting sacrificing and
exchanging the Early Middle game like
this Rook takes H5
looks so nice well first of all I didn't
expect him to play the modern defense
I thought he would repeat the better off
but uh
I mean he played similar line against
Anish and uh
I I guess he wanted to unbalance the
game like and when he played G6 I had a
variety of lines to choose from but
they're all very murky so
and then I just decided to follow the
line that made for the adjustable course
two years ago but this line is very
complex like White Castles long and I
played a lot of Blitz Games in this but
I haven't revealed it and we we have to
get the unclear position no matter what
but when he talks about H5 I just
realized that the fact that exchange but
uh I wasn't sure what was exactly going
on but it looked fun so uh you know it
worked
yeah and then off gravy like I mean
obviously I didn't expect King D5 black
Rook E6 is probably still enough for for
a draw super intense game what's your
approach for tomorrow you are one day
away from winning two hundred thousand
dollars yeah the score one and a half
out of the four uh yeah try to make
friend
I I mean I love that response Mickey's
making some draws that would be a time
thank you very much Wesley back to Danny
I don't know if he was laughing
that he knows he's kind of a draw meme
he knows he's able to make draws on
command better than anybody in the world
or
it was kind of like it was like a what
do you have to do tomorrow and he did he
laid out literally what he has to do I
have to make three draws but guys
we talked about this with him a lot I
know I know Fabi kind of said yesterday
that he thinks sometimes Wesley is
bluffing a little bit and that he's more
confident than he says but Replay that
interview fans at home and everyone he
focused on the match he should have lost
to Jeffrey yeah focused on how well
Nihao played found a way to mention all
of his mistakes Rook takes H5 I mean
it's there is a mindset with Wesley that
I'm I'm I'm confident he plays better
when he's not confident he likes feeling
like he's the underdog and I don't know
what else to say about that even what
the question is but every time I see an
interview his Focus can't he is on what
his opponents are doing well and I think
that gets him in the right mindset it
does in fact it gives us less pressure
it's like well I have nothing to lose I
ain't got nothing to lose right I mean
yeah I am I'm the worst player even
though I'm the official World Champ at
some point and I'm playing for the
finals nib I'm the best record player in
the world whatever good though right did
you hear did you see the Kawaii laugh
bro at the end yeah
it was so great bro to laugh that
reminds me of this famous Michael Jordan
interview after his game sound buzzer
beater and you know they asked him his
thoughts on his performance and he said
it wasn't a swish I'm kidding that
interview never happened I just made
that up
but I think that is the Hallmark of a
player who strives for Perfection there
yeah and they're not doing it out of a
sense of fake modesty that they're doing
it because they truly want to know what
stands between them and actual
Perfection Wesley has come very close to
actual perfection in this tournament
yeah
yeah I'm on you react a little bit of
that too right we've talked about his
mindset his focus on what his opponents
do well and you know you picked Wesley
to win I don't think he would have
picked himself to win based on all the
all the comments that we see him making
exactly like that's just that Eternal
chess player modesty and it's real
modesty you know they they'll always
sell themselves as the underdog and I
think for Wesley the difficult part is
that his resume is bulking up so much
that we're gonna stop believing him and
he says stuff like that but he's always
going to nitpit you know look for that
thing he did wrong and not focus on how
well and how dominant he's been playing
Danny in every single match he's
focusing on one thing with Jeffrey Zhong
and we're focusing on you know what an
insane run he's had and how much he
deserves to be ahead in this match yeah
I'll just uh add a quick anecdote that
there was a similar feeling and a
similar type of Wesley in 2019 I was in
Oslo for the first ever fisherman and
World Chess Championship I know you
joked when when I told you that and you
said yeah give it to him now yeah but I
don't know what it is maybe it's just
because I don't travel much I need to
get out of the house more but being on
site with Wesley again there was an
attitude that he had there that was both
very dialed in but just convinced he had
no chance to win it was like when he won
the tournament I had to remind him in
the interview Wesley you won the
tournament by the way like you won
anyway all right well we're going to
talk about what he needs to do to win
the tournament on Monday in a bit but
lots more of intriguing chess from our
games today so on that note let's send
it back to Robert and Fabi for our brave
move of the day thanks Danny I am here
with five minute karwana and it is time
for the brave move of the day where we
highlight key move or set a moves that
decided the outcome of one of our
matches today from our champion match
we're going to dig into game one where
Wesley so took down nihal sarin with the
white pieces and Fabiano we saw this
moment here C5 was played it looks like
the simple Pawn push attacking the
Knight on D6 but there's way more
calculation than meets the eye yeah this
looks like an amateur move at the start
you just want to attack a knight and
then you see the Knight goes back and
suddenly White's entire Pawn structure
is crumbling but this was a one-two
punch it was based off of the only move
that makes sense of C5 which means that
even though your structure is crumbling
there are a lot more important factors
in the position right because Knight
came into F5 giving up a Pawn on C5 here
Knight C5 queen of three and it wasn't
just one Pawn but two black is up two
full Pawns in the sequence but Bobby
that King on G8 it may look tucked and
safe out there but no it's not you
tucking me and Danny into bed well the
problem for black here is that even
though he's taken two pawns his Knight
is left completely offside one night on
A4 another night on C8 and after white
plays the move Queen to G4 we're
threatening Knight to H6 check all the
voice pieces are needed in the attack
especially these two knights which are
absolute monsters especially the Knight
on F5 this piece not only can it be
extricated from F5 it is jumping into
Black's position with decisive effect
yeah it's a really nasty position and
queen to D7 was played and it wasn't
just the first night Fabi you called it
Knight G6 two knights Galloping into the
position and there are just too many
threats for black to deal with well
let's say black plays any sort of move
here besides what he did which was the
capture Knight let's say he makes
another move saying okay I'm lowering
all your threats like Knight to C3 for
example
now comes the even more devastating blow
Knight to H6 first we have what's almost
like a pseudo Checkmate because Black's
King can't move anywhere forces him to
take the 906 and then we have a
discovered double check you don't see
many of those Knight to E7 black can't
take the queen on G4 because it's also a
check from the Knight on E7 the king can
move to either one of two squares but it
doesn't matter where it goes because in
both cases it is Checkmate Queen to G8
King T8 E8 and now Knight takes C8 with
another Discovery and black is losing
all his pieces followed by getting
checkmated right at the end of it you'll
have to do something like this and that
is check and made so in the game and
after Knight G6 that night was captured
but when the pawn took back in comes
this queen to deliver a mate they're
just a few moves left Knight E7 let's
sack The Rook for the night and then the
best one was Queen takes if you took
with the bishop you may think you're up
a rook you're gonna win this game but
after move like Queen to H3 there's
check and Checkmate Unstoppable Wesley
so from game one with that C5 move he
went on to lead today's action three to
one and that's our brave move of the day
remember it's time to make your move
from chrome to Brave try it now at
brave.com chess let's send it back to
Danny of friends in the playing Hall
great stuff and great break down there
Robert and Fabi let's check back in with
the scores again to show everybody where
we sit it is three to one in favor of
Wesley so that game really set things
off so all right we uh we have games
ahead we got more games on Monday but we
don't know how many we're gonna have
depending on what happens in the first
two games as everyone can see from the
scoreboard fellas we will have at least
two games to get to four and a half
points you need at least two to get one
half out of two but what do we think is
going to happen in those two games do we
think we're all done here after uh six
games total or do you think we're gonna
go a little further than that Danny I
think we are going to go a little bit
further than that and I think nihal
needs to get back to that fighting style
where it feels like he's ready to play
every game for a win here I felt in this
match so far like he was ready to take a
draw with Wesley in certain positions
and I know that you know the position is
kind of liquidated down but still even
in positions that were 0.00 on the
engines we always saw that willingly
this from nihal to let's play it out
even if it's 100 moves and it ends up in
a draw anyway let's play it out tire out
your opponent you might get some chances
he's won the most improbable positions
so I think we're gonna see a different
nihal tomorrow where he realizes he has
to fight now and so he's not just gonna
be making draws in 20 moves Danny
because that's not an option all right
Amman thinks we're going further than
six games this will not be over in six
you agree uh yeah in fact I think it's
uh it's gonna be over I think it's over
now I disagree with him 100 button I
love my guy but I know that it's just
over right now this is over he ain't
coming back because ikaru couldn't come
back that's just my logic area you
couldn't me Carl couldn't beat him he
couldn't get through it we went the
whole distance and he couldn't do it and
then nihal is not having the openings
right now it's not working for him he's
down right now he took the draw to Sykes
there do I where my openings at can't
find him where's the files right what is
this it's a lot of confusion I think so
I think this is in the bag two games and
now it draws what do you think I think
Neil's only chance is to make very
drastic opening changes I think he
should play one E4 with white and he
should perhaps Channel Dimitri on draken
and play a sicilian like he needs to
just change everything up completely
obviously playing Wesley's super
deflating and as Iman said he just
seemed so deflated by the end of today
like no matter what I do I get a winning
position Wesley just finds 800 computer
moves and pulls off a win so he's got to
get out of that negative mindset and
focus on the positive which is that he's
had a ridiculous run to get here it'll
be a success regardless of how he does
and so he might as well try to give
Wesley a run for his money well you know
what he literally was down a game
against Savion he didn't complete a
two-game comeback yeah but he turned the
match around by two games total so I
don't know that it's totally over yet
this game can be a game of momentum and
the thing about these formats the rapid
formats we do the speed Transformers we
do we always say that once the day
starts it can really set things in
motion because you don't get a rest day
if you have a bad game you don't even
get more than 20 minutes right so if
something does start to unravel the
emotions can be hard to handle right and
and I think that that's why I'm curious
if nihow can just get one win on the
board what could that do for him not
just his confidence Wesley doesn't play
as well when he's not in the zone right
he can be a player that gets rattled too
so obviously like all fans at home I'm
sitting here on my couch hoping that
it's more than six games so that's my
maybe thought to leave it on but uh but
yeah I genuinely do believe if nihal
wins we could have a long day so all
right before we head out always wanted
to be a chess streamer already have a
channel but looking to grow your
audience to the likes of Hikaru Gotham
chess or the bow Tes sisters the
chess.com streamer program brings your
stream to the world's biggest chess
platform with new features that increase
your Channel's visibility and promote
your presence in the chess Community
streamers are listed at chess.com
sorry guys everybody boop boop chess.com
streamers on their chess.com profile all
you have to do is connect your Twitch
account to your account on chess.com set
your Twitch category to chess and start
streaming throw in the command starts
streaming in the chat for all the
details
that's a that's a wrap for us from the
one Hotel in Toronto for today big
thanks to Amman Canty Fabiano Donya
Robert all the gang every all our
commentators for another great day of
live chess here at the cgc tomorrow we
Crown a champion
make sure to join us tomorrow on Twitch
and YouTube as we wrap up our coverage
of the cgc title match the chess starts
at noon 9 A.M Pacific time that's noon
Eastern for now I'm Danny wrench good
night from Toronto thanks for being with
us we will make sure to see you tomorrow
as things kick off like we said at noon
Eastern Time 9 A.M Pacific we will see
you then
foreign
[Music]
thank you
look back
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign